Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is the voice, the prophet,
the evangelist of all things Action Sports, Selema Masekela.
If you follow surfing, if you follow action sports
then chances are you already know this man well.
He's a bad-ass athlete, a musician
a beloved television commentator, a journalist, a host
and an Emmy nominated producer,
best known as the face of the X-Games.
Over the years, he's also worked with E, NBC, ABC Nat Geo
Red Bull Media and Vice.
His bio is great
but I got to say it does very little
to convey the sheer awesomeness of this conversation.
Selema's story is unreal.
He is a truly gifted storyteller
and I don't really know what else to say.
Other than that, this episode is just elite.
So hit that subscribe button and let's do the thing.
This is me and Selema Masekela.
Let's rock.
So-
I'm so envious of your setup.
It's good, man, well welcome.
We're all super happy to have you here.
I've been looking forward to this for a long time
and you know it's interesting
about how you came to be here today.
I think it was around December several months ago
within a period, like a span of about three days,
at least three different people brought your name up to me,
Russell Nadel at Jaybird
Wow.
and Caroline Burckle who, you know from Deuce.
and oh my boy DK who's friends with like your neighbor
or something like that like your name just kept coming up.
Oh yeah, he's friends with Deb.
Like oh, do you know this guy?
And then, you know, that resulted in some emails
that ended up having you here today
but the message that I get from that,
like, I've I've just learned over the years
when the universe is speaking in that kind of way,
you pay attention, like you abide, right?
How do you feel about that?
A wholeheartedly abide by that?
I literally just, I sent that text off
to someone this morning
that I was trying to get on my podcast.
And they responded, I'm a DM person
because I don't have a Booker yet.
So I'm like, all right, like DMs consistently work.
If I send like a genuine message
it doesn't hurt that there's a blue chip there
that maybe they'll pay attention to.
And I'm this guy hit me back today
and he's like I'm so humbled that you that you asked,
like, here's my team's email.
And if we can make it work, we will,
I was like, no problem
and I will hit up your team
and the universe will handle the rest.
Yeah, well, the DMs are the way to go,
I don't have a Booker.
You know, it's all about that personal connection.
You know, if that person had been on the receiving end
of an email from a Booker, they might've just dismissed it.
Yeah, yeah.
But you reaching out to that person personally
that leaves a different impression.
I agree.
It took me a while to get comfortable asking
reaching out to people to collaborate on anything.
I suffered from a bit of a imposter syndrome
in my head sometimes about like,
am I worthy to engage with this person who I admire?
And I really had to work to get over that
to be like feel confident in that there's something there
reach out the worst thing that anyone can say is no.
Yeah you and me, both brother,
but it's so funny hearing that from you
because you know, and that's kind of like a theme
or a thread that shows up periodically
throughout your story.
You having to overcome that aspect of yourself
in order to make your way.
But looking at you now it's like, you're the dude,
like who's not going to respond to your DM,
you know, on paper, it seems silly
that you would lapse into that kind of self judgment.
It's a continued work in progress
and I've had to really like take the time to dig deep
to choose, to be like, okay, where's this come from?
You know, because sometimes it can, as you know
it can be wildly debilitating
and you can cut yourself off from so much joy,
just because of this voice
that you would never be friends with you,
that voice inhabited a body
you'd never nothing to do with that person
because it exists within you.
Sometimes it can literally just like,
for me sometimes it can literally like
take over like be like cloaking device
and I'll forget, oh I'll get lost in between
like what's real and what's that voice.
Yeah, I can't tell you how many times
I haven't reached out to somebody because I'm scared
or I think they don't want to hear from me
and then ultimately something happens years later
where I do and they're like, what's your problem, man?
(laughing)
I feel so seen right now.
Where do I Venmo you for this therapy?
I'll be even mowing you, my friend.
Yeah, it's funny.
I mean, you know, I've heard you recount your story
a couple of times and that does show up throughout it.
So do you mind, can we like do this,
can we start at the beginning?
Sure.
We got time, man.
We're gonna take our time today.
Let's go.
You don't have to be anywhere, do you?
Yeah, no, I literally blocked out the afternoon for you.
Yeah cool.
Taking it all the way back to you as a kid.
I mean, your background, your origin stories.
So super interesting and dynamic and diverse
the way that you were brought up
by two very different parents
that, you know looking through the rear view mirror,
it all adds up like, it all makes sense.
But the fact that you ended up where you ended up
like seems so strange compared to where you came from.
It's wild, it really is.
I mean, I grew up,
my father was a political exile from South Africa
and a musician and a freedom fighter an activist.
Because of being an exile
he never took citizenship any place else.
So he had the opportunity to take roots in America
or in the UK and he chose not to.
And he chose to through his music
be a person who was going to fight for the end of apartheid
when everyone else was like, oh, you're crazy.
What was the vibe around him in South Africa
before he migrated over to the U.S?
He was just starting to bubble.
You know, he was a young talent
that had been playing the black music circuit
in South Africa and he was just starting to bubble
but he hadn't exploded yet.
He was in this band called the Jazz Epistles
that he had with a few friends and they were making noise
and they were also making under underground,
they were making music with white kids
that were of the same mindset, which was totally illegal.
So he wasn't famous yet
but he was very much on the radar of the police
and the secret police.
So he had to split.
He had the split.
They showed up at my grandmother's,
his grandmother's house, I think a day or two
after he left the country, looking for him.
And it was kind of thing of like get arrested
or and or die while being in captivity, you know.
How old was he then?
It was 1920.
Wow, wow.
So it comes to the U.S.
And does he, where does he come first, to New York?
New York.
He goes to New York first.
Yeah, he goes to New York-
'Cause you guys ended up bouncing around.
Yeah, New York, dead of winter never seen snow before
very African kid in 1959-
Was there anyone, you know when he landed to greet him,
like, did he know anybody
was there any extended family or anything like that?
So Miriam Makeba, who was a a prolific musician
and singer an activist.
She came first and Harry Belafonte
had really acted as a mentor for her
and helped her establish herself here.
And she told Harry like, hey, there's another guy
who's amazing, his name is Hugh.
You got to get him here.
And so my dad went to London for a short time
and then Harry sent for my father,
sent him a plane ticket and brought him to New York and-
it's pretty dope.
enrolled him
in the Manhattan School of Music.
And acted as a mentor to, and was really
like Iowa, Harry Belafonte, basically my existence.
Right, have you, have you spent time on him,
did you tell him?
Yeah, I know him,
well, I spend a lot of time with him growing up,
I mean, he's always been my uncle Harry.
Yeah, and yeah, I was actually right when COVID was hitting
I was actually going to sit down with him
to do like a master interview,
about his lens into my father first showing up.
My dad passed three years ago.
Yeah, yeah, yeah it was just the anniversary
is a couple days ago.
Right, his birthday was a couple days ago
on Sunday, April 4th.
And then his anniversary was January 28th.
And you know, you don't,
you don't get used to it.
You know, it's a grief hits with different signatures
and notes that are sharp and flat
as the dance continues.
It sounded like it was quite a roller coaster for you.
It was crazy.
Like when it happened, it was really, really, really crazy.
Yeah, but yeah.
But when he passed, you guys were good?
We were great.
When my father passed we were best friends.
You know, we had gone through all of our shit.
We had really developed a beautiful, beautiful friendship.
Starting, I'd say around 30s
when we really got to know know each other.
And we became boys, you know,
like really boys and mutual supporters.
He really became a supporter of mine
in what I was doing and that meant-
Musically too, right?
I know he's on one of those one song.
Yeah, we did a song together.
We did a song together in 2016 for my last album.
And the song was called "In an Age."
And that was always a dream of mine,
you know, to get to work with my father.
But I didn't ask him, I never asked him
that the first album I made
I didn't even tell him I was making it
Because of the imposter syndrome?
Because of the imposter syndrome
and because I think my dad forgot,
I know he forgot that I was musical as a kid.
I think that part had just like left the story.
And he only saw me as this,
you know this surfer, snowboarder, skateboarder now.
And inside I always felt this itch,
like I gotta get back to music, I got it back to music.
And so in 2011 is when I started making my first record.
I played it for him,
I gave him a copy of the record and he called me
and he said, man, you know, I listened to this record, man
and it's beautiful, man,
I forgot that you could sing like that.
Said, it's you no, he said, if I could sing like you man,
I wouldn't even bother to sing anymore,
I would just play my own.
And that was just like, you know
I never thought he'd ever see me that way.
Yeah, I gather he wasn't a guy
who is easy with the compliments.
I was scared shitless of what the review was gonna be.
Like he easily would have been like,
I'm proud of you that you finally scratch this itch
and I hope you never do it again.
Like he would have been very lovingly said like
don't mess up the name, let's forget that this happened.
And then the next thing that he said to me was
you just got to promise me one thing.
And I said, what?
If you decide to do this again
and you better call me to be on the next one.
And he was like, legit taste that he wasn't on the album.
And that was, that just broke my brain.
I'm like what?
He's like, yeah, man, I gotta be on the next one.
Let's do some together.
And so I called him for the next one
and he was in South Africa.
And he said, I'm coming over.
And he bought a ticket and he came and stayed for two weeks
and came to be on the record
and we had a blast and it was just like,
that was just like,
you don't know that you're ever gonna get that
with your parents, you know?
Like I never would have, could have ever imagined
that I get to get into that with my dad.
It's beautiful man.
I listened to the song the other day, I love it.
I assume he's the one playing the horn, yeah?
He's the one on the horn and rapping.
Oh really he's always rapping.
So I wrote that rap for him,
my cousin, Sonny and I we wrote the rap for him
because he had a song in the '80s
called Don't Go Bose It Baby.
That was a big, like a dance hit, English dance hit.
And he, I remember being in the studio with him
and he was excited that he was gonna rap.
He's like, I'm doing that rap thing, man.
You know, I want you to be here with me.
And I'm a kid I'm like 11, 12, and I'm a hip hop kid.
What are you doing, dad?
And he goes, and then he's just like spitfire like
drops these incredible bars
and like the song ends up being a huge hit.
So when Sonny and I were working on this record,
we were like let's do an ode to Don't Go Lose It Baby
for him and see if dad still got buyers.
And he comes in at like 74 years old
and just jobs, fire.
Sort of for him to be rapping and me singing over it
and it's just like it was beautiful, man.
It was really, really beautiful.
Yeah, he really made a name for himself.
It seems like it didn't take that long
like he was playing with everyone.
Yeah, I mean his contemporaries at the time,
you know as a kid, when he came to to New York
where, you know it was dizzy Gillespie,
you know, it was miles.
It, you know, he came in straight
into the the bebop scene and going
to Manhattan school of music.
Like he was in the mix with all these musicians.
Right, they went to clubs in the daytime
and sat in and played.
And it was a whole different energy, you know?
And the thing that was interesting is that those musicians
would be like, we love that you play our that you play
like the bebop, but like.
They'd be like, play some of that African, man.
Play us some of your Yushin.
And he thought that he, when he first came here
that he needed to be this bebop dude.
And they're like, not man do your thing it is.
And that's why he was able to create what he did
'cause no one else had it.
And he basically was the father
of what you would call world beat music,
you know, as a result.
He came out to LA and in like '66-67
and he and Stuart Levine who was his classmates,
a Jewish kid from the Bronx.
They became best friends, they moved to LA together,
they start a studio and started a label
and they start making records.
And then don't go grazing in the grass
was like the rocket launcher in '68.
Right and that's around the time you were born, born here?
I was here in '71 I was in Los Angeles.
But you guys jetted back to New York.
Yeah, my mother.
So my dad was getting after it.
It's the late 60s, early '70s you know.
I'm trying to draw a mental picture.
And he was cutting a figure
Getting after it.
And also like, as you hear, many of those old timers say
that the drugs were good then,
and they had yet deal with like real consequence
from drugs.
And I knew it was just
Well, there wasn't an awareness of the consequences
like there is now right there.
Right so it was just part of how you live.
Yeah, yeah.
And he's dragging you along,
you're in all these clubs and around all these cats.
Yeah, it was a little kid,
you know, when I was just a baby he's dragging my mom along
and my mom reaches a point where she's like,
I love you but I'm not raising a baby like this.
And so she breaks out to New York and goes back to New York.
And we moved with my grandmother.
My grandmother immigrated from Haiti.
My mom came here when she was like
probably six or seven years old.
And then my dad comes a few years later
and sets up shop in New York city.
And I didn't really come into like
knowledge of him as my father
until about four or five years old.
That's when, like I have my presence of him being my dad.
He was this cool guy who was around
but I didn't really-
Connect the dots on that-
because I left at such a formative,
you know, like to, it was when we left.
And so my earliest memories of my dad are like in the club.
Like on the weekends, when my dad had me
he was playing gigs and I was in the club,
five, six years old, you know, bouncing around
from table to table at two in the morning, talking to adults
and like watching my father like
really steal people's souls.
And I fell in love with his magic from a little kid
you know, every time that I got to go to watch my dad play
was the best 'çause I would just be there in awe
and each time felt like the first.
Right, and to see everybody else
in awe of him as well that must've been-
To see him the way he could command,
win a crowd really storytell,
like the time that he took in-between songs
to explain to people why and how a song came to be
and tell stories about South Africa
and this place that he missed so desperately
and make them feel a reason to care
and want to want to know more.
Because at the time, you know
most people don't don't realize it,
but America was very, very much a solid supporter
of the apartheid regime.
Yeah, we were very late to the party
in terms of reckoning with that.
Late, late, late, in fact, Korean president Bryden
was like one of the first people to step up and put
the entire Senate and in Congress on blast,
like, no, we can't do this.
And here's why there's a really legendary speech,
if you Google like just Bryden.
South Africa where,
you know the Republicans are trying to
Or the one from way back in the day?
Yeah I've seen that.
He's like brand new, I think.
Brand new, I knew it was a young dude
and he's like, nah, this, this doesn't stand.
That was radical at the time.
It was very, very, very radical at the time
because the, you know, our government
who was very much in Allyship with the apartheid government
and did a very good job of being like,
it's not racist what's going on down there, it's necessary,
I mean, the natives, they're wild, they're Africans.
Yeah, and your dad felt so strongly about it
that he never got citizenship in the States, right?
He maintained a South African citizenship.
We've maintained the South African Citizenship
because he knew that one day it was gonna end.
And his thing was like as soon as this shit is over,
I'm going home.
And literally like as soon as president
then the clerk realized like
if we don't start to bring these expats home
and like the South African country was a tinderbox, you know
the violence and the protests of you know,
a majority, you know, indigenous South African people
being ruled by a minority white people,
and the laws were insane.
Like insidiously evil, you know, you had needed a passport.
Like let's say for me to come from Venice to see you today.
Just to travel from town to town, I needed a passport,
I needed a reason and I needed to be out of here
by like 7:00 PM.
All right.
And if I got stopped or pulled over
the first thing that they were gonna say is like
show me your passbook.
Fucking crazy.
Why are you not where you live?
You know, that was just one of the things.
And the only reason why I would be moving someplace
where I didn't live is because I was coming to work for you,
essentially.
And that was just one of the many, many things,
I mean, my father's family home was like raised in torn down
and in the late 40's, early 50's
and they were my grandfather who had done well
who worked for the government
and was a sculptor and an artist
and my grandmother who was a social worker,
like they had a life.
I mean this picked our whole family up
and put them in a township and said
we're going to reserve these areas for.
Structural property.
Yeah, took the property and you know, piece out.
So yeah, I mean, I'm always fascinated by my dad's belief
that that is thorough, innate belief
that this system will be overrun
and will end and I'll go home.
Right, it's a deep conviction that fueled a certain strain
of activism and what he did
and what he expressed in his music, how he carried himself,
the decisions that he made.
And I think about that in juxtaposition to your own career
and it's interesting how, you know,
your relationship with activism is different.
Like, you're somebody who's, you know,
unique in the sort of power that you wield
and the situations that you find yourself in
being one of the few black people in a whitewashed world,
but somebody who is always, you know,
and please correct me if I'm wrong,
seem to be more interested in making things work
and fitting in and not drawing undue attention
to the racism that you experienced.
And it only is in, you know, sort of recent years
or perhaps even in the past year
where you've kind of shoulder this mantle
in a way that perhaps your father
would have related to, right?
With black lives matter and everything that's happening
and surfing, et cetera.
Yeah, that is an accurate lens.
When you are an only operating in a space where 99.9%
of the people don't look like you,
especially as a young person,
you work very hard to gain acceptance.
And I sacrificed a lot of myself
in order to stay close to what I love doing
and figured out how to win people over, you know,
how to gain acceptance, how to be allowed in.
It took me a very long time.
You know, I moved to Southern California when I was 16
and surfing and snowboarding changed my life.
It took me, I'd say about a little over a decade
to like, like wait a minute.
This space is yours just as much as it is theirs
Right.
And this idea that you have to keep
like making yourself smaller
and also put up with like consistently just consistent micro
and also like outright aggression because of my race.
And that aggression also could be in the form of jokes,
in people wanting to like, you know,
really highlight the fact that I'm different.
But their interest in my being different
stopped at my skin color and there was no curiosity
around who I was, where I came from
and why this experience might be different
for me than it is for you.
Right, in the commentator space, this idea that
there's some tokenism at play,
like let's get the black guy in here and then surprise
when you actually knew you were talking about
and then shock when people discover
that you actually could do all the stuff that
(Rich laughs)
All of those.
You are commentating on, right?
All of those things, all of those things.
I mean, people used to come up to me
and stop me all the time
as I really started to like gain notoriety via the X Games
and be like, I think it's just genius that E.S.P.N,
you know has put you in this position.
What was the teaching process like?
Because clearly you don't do those things
but you're so knowledgeable
and the way the athletes react to you,
it's almost like they know you.
(Rich laughs)
It could be that you're actually part of the community.
Well, I actually I'm a snowboarder and I'm a surfer
and I come from skateboarding
and like I've been doing this a very long time.
And so I'm actually super qualified to be here
and they're like, oh, well into this,
isn't that cute, you know?
But you just start all along the way,
just trying to make it work, you know.
You try to make it work.
You try to make it work but then like,
there are things that happen behind the scenes
as you're dealing with an already shitty business.
Like the entertainment business
it's not a noble place to play
when it comes to like the power wielding
that networks and platforms have
and you being a talent being very disposable.
And it's double down when it comes to race and gender,
it's just, it is what it is.
I mean, I can't tell you how many times
I'd be going out for jobs
where an agent felt comfortable to say to me, like,
yeah, you know, that is a great place for you
but they already have a black guy in Prime Time.
We should think of someplace else.
I'd be like, did you hear what you just said?
Because there's one person on that network
that looks like me in a sea of white people,
we should go someplace.
They've already checked that box.
That box is checked
and I dealt with a lot of that box is checked
and people thinking that because that E.S.P.N had like
had a magic golden box check
in my being the host of the X Games,
then my becoming this voice and face of the culture,
like it was organized, like, and I didn't like bleed for it.
And I wasn't, you know, answering the phones as an intern
at Transworld Skateboarding and Snowboarding magazine
and, you know, fighting tooth and nail
to stay as close to the culture as possible.
Do you feel like you sort of suppressed those emotions
that came up with that experience
just to, you know, just to get along?
I did.
Get along to go along, like,
you know I'm thinking about the,
I watched the speech that you gave at the paddle out
over black lives matter and George Floyd,
where I don't know how many people showed up for that
look like couple thousands,
a couple thousand surfers
and you give this incredibly emotional,
powerful, poignant speech up on the bluffs
before the paddle out
and it was so like moving and authentic
and I wondered whether that was the first time
that you ever kind of gave public voice
to what you were experiencing.
And it felt like a Rubicon to me,
like you'd stepped over a certain line
and decided that, you know, enough is enough
and now I'm gonna shoulder some responsibility,
you know, given the position that I'm in
to speak to these matters.
Yeah, the first time for me was a piece
that I did with the Inertia
probably about seven, eight years ago.
That was the first time that I just like really talked about
what it's like to be a labeled as to be a black surfer
in this world.
And that was the first time that I got people being like
hey, that was, what are you talking about bro?
Like, we've always been cool.
We don't see color.
I'm like, yeah, that's actually the problem.
And you don't know what it's been like for me
and you've never asked and you don't care.
You know, people thinking that they're, you know,
well-meaning when they,
you know, you're out on a boat trip
and it's late and the sun setting
and you're paddling back to the boat
'cause you're one of the last people in the water
and someone thinking it's cute to be like, smile
so we can see you,
you know, that type of shit.
And it was just endless versions
of what that's looked like for me and my in, you know,
I can't got let go from a surf shop
that I always wanted to work at and as a kid notion side
because the owners literally told the managers
like he doesn't fit the image of the shop
and it's gonna be bad for business
so tell him that it's slow and we had to like, let him go.
Like you know, things like that,
that just like as in your teen years,
it just so you're like, wait what?
So yeah, I think that moment speaking up on the bluff
in the midst of like so much that you've just like contained
and not shared to like, as you said,
move forward and keep the peace.
The idea that people would see me as a lot,
I would hear people be like,
when the conversations first started happening
in the action sports base, I'd see people publicly like
use my name to be like, well we have some as Keller,
you know, bad one when I went buy cell.
Like, what do you do?
And I'd be like, wait,
you think some sort of like force field
for the massive amount of like,
just whiteness that exists here that you'd like shine me
as some sort of like powering to tell people like,
look, see what we haven't taken care of, everyone relax.
He's the loudest, he's the most prominent face in our deal
that takes care of it.
Like, well, where are the people in the playing field
getting to live this lifestyle and culture
and why is it that that exists?
You know, and I think before outwardly speaking
like that one that time on the bluff
and obviously in the wake of Ahmaud Arbery, George Floyd,
Breonna Taylor it was like, in the midst of COVID
was a very like, I mean history is gonna look back
at like a time when in the midst
of like the most distracted that we've ever been
because of this crazy new digital landscape
that we've created, this augmented reality
that is like an infant, that we're all just learning to play
in and can just be busy, busy, busy, busy, busy,
someone's I do live TV, this and that like literally,
like I don't have to pay attention to anything
because there's always something to take my attention,
COVID happens and just shuts all that shit down, right?
Everyone's attention, our level of connection is heightened
because we're all going through the thing together
and no one, no matter how much money, race, whatever
nobody can hide, you are affected.
And to me it feels like having that framework laid,
whereas we're all existing in the same thing
for the first time that I can remember,
and then having Ahmaud Arbery, having George Floyd,
having Breonna Taylor happened
and people not being able to hide or ignore it.
It meant that whatever, you know,
the response was going to be something
you didn't have a choice, but to pay attention to.
And whatever subcultures and subgroups
that have been able to like just quietly exist
with the imbalance
and sort of accepted light to medium racism
as well as just complete lack of inclusion
that all, like there was no place to hide
and it ended up being this very interesting
like halogen blacklight, right?
That like, whatever space it's like, you know,
we're going to talk about it in this space.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think you nailed it with that
this crazy petri dish where everyone's stuck at home
and we have to contend with this thing in a very real
and uncomfortable way that one would hope
or aspire would unite us.
And in truth ended up really kind of elucidating the extent
of the divide that exists.
Really did.
And always has existed.
You know, it sort of brought all of that out underneath
a political environment that gave permission to a lot of
Full license, full license.
Like it leading up to that paddle out.
You know, I live in Venice and the initial protest
that became strong engagements with the police
and the ensuing looting that took place
like that was happening like a few blocks from me.
Helicopters over ahead 24/7, gunshots popping off,
there was a murder, you know, the shootout with police
like two blocks away from my crib, like shit was real.
And I remember there was a shot of a surf shop
in Santa Monica that was being looted.
And there were white people that were.
Were looting it.
Which one, DJs?
It wasn't DJs, it was a place on the prominent
or in and around the prominent.
But you know there was a shot
like and it included white people running out
with surfboards and wetsuits and all sorts of shit.
Whilst you're hearing this growing like really big
it is audience within the action sports base,
like really being like look at those people,
look at the blacks, look at the browns,
look at what they're doing.
And that, that, that and like this righteous anger
this righteous conservative anger
that was taking place already because of COVID
and now like a real opportunity for like blame.
And so I posted a clip of those white people,
you know running out with surfboards
and jumping on the back of like jumping into cars
and jumping on the back of scooters and stuff.
And I was like, where are y'all now?
Where are y'all now?
What that comment section look like?
(all laughs)
It was lit up like the 4th of July
I mean, I can't tell you how many DMS
from people being like, hey man, like,
we've always accepted you
and why are you like, I'm like, what?
Why am I like demonstrably black in the midst of injustice?
Do you all not know where and what I come from?
Like, oh, you thought that I feel like I won something
to gain to have received your approval for how I live.
No, we're not doing that anymore.
And it was definitely the time for me
where it was like, who are you the son of?
Right, that's what I was gonna ask
like, at what point does the legacy
of your father start to work on your, you know,
unconscious to motivate you to step into this?
I mean, obviously at some level it's bred into you.
And I would suspect that there have probably been times
in your younger years where you thought
my dad would have handled this differently
or why am I not stepping up in the way that he did
like following this example that he said
which was so courageous.
Definitely, I didn't know how, and I also had the,
there was a confliction in how I was raised,
because as much as my father.
You pissed him too.
(Rich laughs)
There was like this partial, like he was my hero
and I was also pissed at him
because he was battling addiction
and the clear side effects of what that means
in a father, son, or any parent child relationship.
And then on the side, my mother and stepfather
were raising me as a very, very hardcore Jehovah's Witness,
where I'm going to church three to five weeks
and it's super conservative on every level.
And I'm knocking on people's doors every Saturday morning
and telling them like, you know, listen to this
so that you can make it into living forever.
And your mom's like a big organic.
Yeah, and my mom's.
Took on it, right?
Like she's putting you on the Venice Health trip, you know.
My mom's put me on the, well, yes,
she's putting me on the Venice Health trip
in the 70's and my mom was like,
my stepfather was the conservative
like the ultra conservative one and then my mom.
He was the Jehovah's Witness, right?
Yeah, my mother was Jehovah's Witness too,
but she was also like.
We all ran this guy.
It was also like, you know, like,
I'm also like hardcore into my alternative medicine
and like, if y'all think I'm a witch, cool,
but like this is my shit, you know?
So she had that little bit of
That's a fucking brew for you to come up in.
So all of that intertwined together, you find yourself
and then you add to that like leaving New York City
at 13, 14 years of age,
where I am in the midst of like a multitude of race,
the gender conversation is already handled.
Like I got my friend with two moms,
I got my friend with two dads
like all that shit is done.
Like, you have real knowledge of people's immigrant stories
and their cultures and the music and their food
and their song and all the things that makes them them
like, that's enriches your community
and it enriches how you live
and you're celebrating each other.
So you just figure like, the rest of the world is that way,
you know, and then you move
my mother and stepfather moved
to consistently very white spaces.
First in New England
in the end of my junior year of high school
and then to, you know, Southern California
where none of that existed.
I mean, it's like going to the moon
Literally.
From being in New York City.
I mean I'm at the club with Miles Davis.
Right, literally.
Literally, right?
Yeah.
And then you're in Carlsbad
like where it's just strip malls in the beach.
Yeah.
So strange and what's interesting
about your New York experience,
I mean, you're steeped in the arts
you're studying acting, you're doing gymnastics,
you're hanging out with your dad, you're doing music.
I mean, it's such a robustly, culturally diverse experience.
Like most athletes, they are kind of reared to be athletes
and artists are reared to be artists
and you have this very strange, unique combination
of these two worlds that make you fascinating.
You know, I wonder had you never moved to Carlsbad
or to New England and you just stayed in New York City
what life would have looked like,
like would you have just become a musician
or an actor or a filmmaker?
I mean, you're doing a lot of these things now
but without the snowboarding and the surfing.
I think that, that's where my head was.
You know, I wanted to go to LaGuardia.
I wanted to go to this to school.
Yeah, I wanted to go to the LaGuardia that was my goal.
I played basketball.
I was athletic, I did gymnastics as a kid in New York,
but like I wanted to be in the arts.
I didn't know how I would get there
because of like running up against this wall
with my stepdad,
but that was what I was always fighting for.
I played in the band and in the Philharmonic
all the way from like elementary through junior high school,
we were competitive like our band would compete
against bands all through the city
like that was just a part of how we grew up.
And that changed when, you know, when we moved.
I think I went, when we first moved to New England,
my freshman year, they didn't have like a Philharmonic
or a jazz band so I was like, all right,
I'll go out for the marching band.
And they're playing shit that we were playing
like five, six years ago.
And I'm wearing this flammable polyester thing
with just white people and I was like, ah, I can't do it.
Why did you move up there?
Was it like a church thing?
You know my step dad, it was a semi church thing,
my stepdad wanted to go and work.
He had aspirations for sort of moving up in the church
and he wanted to go to a congregation that needed more help,
more people that came, he was a fantastic speaker,
like kind of like a funny dude
and also like, he had a way of like,
distilling like Bible talks into like real,
every man kind of speech
and he was really artful with it.
And so he was popular, you know,
and he liked the idea of becoming, you know,
he wanted to be like an overseer.
There's just like different levels.
You can be a servant and then you become an elder
and your goal would be like to be an overseer.
And that's what he, so he raised us to be like, hey,
this is a theocratic family, and this is our main goal.
Anything else is extra and if any of those other things
are getting in the way of this thing, they're out.
And was there like a puritanism to that as well
that was at odds with, you know,
hanging out in the jazz clubs?
Oh my God, I'm like
(all laughs)
Right?
When would go to see my dad
I literally would have to like spend a day
like reintegrating and like taking off
my church version of myself and being okay.
And my dad would like encourage me be like,
don't worry about, you know,
you don't have to be square here, man.
Like just you're cool.
I'll be like really, cool?
You know, you're hanging out with jazz musicians
who are, you know, smoking weed
and talking to all sorts of shit
and I got to like be witness
to like these incredibly talented unedited human beings.
What do you remember about that?
Like, do you have memories of interacting with Miles Davis?
I do, I remember the first time I met Miles.
You know he's real like you know, raspy
talking about, you know, your father
and you're cool boy.
And you're like, I didn't know what that was at the time
but then years later you're like.
That's insane.
Oh my God.
What, like I knew that guy.
You know, it's Stevie Wonder, I mean,
just endless people of that era.
And, you know, Herb Alpert, my dad was making records
with Herb Alpert, so many different people.
But that switching gears like
that chameleon ask, you know, kind of scan
that you had adorn to go back and forth
between those two very different worlds.
And now the people pleasing thing
kind of makes a little bit more sense.
Yeah, I'd go home and I'd just have to like switch it up.
And my stepfather was watching to see
if I brought any of it home.
And, you know, they definitely was another
like re-integration into how I acted around my friends
and how I acted at church and what I could
and couldn't talk about.
And then like how I acted at school, you know,
it was definitely a dance
and God forbid your friends find out
that you're one of those Jehovah's
and then they're gonna have a field day with you,
or you knock on, you know, you knock on someone's door
and like there's your friends that opened the door
and they're like what are you doing?
Like what?
Right, but at the same time,
being in Carlsbad and not New York City,
freed you from the long shadow that being his son
would have, you know, would have been like for you,
how do you stay in the city?
Totally was no one knew no one cared like a teacher or two
who was like, well-versed, my English teacher especially
who I'm super grateful for.
My English teacher in my senior year, Mrs. Frank,
if I wouldn't have had her
I don't know what would have happened.
She was the one who'd be like, hey, come here.
I see what you're trying to do here
and I can imagine it's hard,
but also like I see what you're made of,
and I know what you come from
and I can't let you like bro out.
So we're gonna mine you for what your worth is
'cause I see it and I will not let you hide.
You know, she's not gonna let you dumb it down
to hang with the groms.
No, absolutely not.
(Rich laughs)
And she was a gift, she was the one
who really like helped me see that I had a potential beyond
and not to let the place take me over.
But yeah, there was this freedom and like,
oh, no one knows or cares who my dad is, this is cool.
And as I've said, many times, like, you know,
surfing really became my music, you know,
surfing and snowboarding,
especially I was skating at the time a bit
but surfing and snowboarding really became my music.
They became how I dreamed
and how I thought about everything.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But first I do wanna snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is most people I know actually aspire
to eat better, to incorporate more whole plants,
fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans and legumes
into their daily regimen.
Sadly, however, without the proper tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
And so, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everyone to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
And the solution we've devised, I'm proud to say
is the Plantpower Meal Planner.
Are affordable all in one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access to thousands
of customizable, super delicious,
easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery.
You get access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many many other amazing features.
To learn more and sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHealth at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff
literally for just a dollar 70 a week,
price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.rich roll.com promo code RRHealth
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, back to the pod.
So snowboarding, I assume, came into the picture
when you moved out to New England.
No snowboarding came into the picture
when I moved to Carlsbad
because big bear is only an hour and a half away.
All right.
So I started surfing, six months later
everyone starting to snowboard, you know,
a bunch of friends say like, hey, we're going snowboarding.
The first time I went snowboard I was wearing a full suit.
(all laughs)
A full suit and circles.
Well, I wanna walk us up to the point
where you're first introduced with surfing.
My understanding is that your first sort of glimpse of it
was when you went on tour with your dad, right?
So he gets picked up by Paul Simon
to go on the Graceland tour.
Yeah.
And you're in Sydney, right?
Yes.
I hadn't seen my dad for about four and a half, five years
because he had decided to go and make music in Africa.
Like he couldn't go to South Africa,
but he just had to be on the continent.
So after my fifth grade graduation,
he just like pulled up and was gone.
I got a saxophone for my birthday
and then I didn't see my dad for like four and a half years
which was a trip, like we'd write letters,
talk on the phone once in a while.
But he was on a quest.
It was a wall.
Trying to get as close as possible
to the thing as possible.
So real artist.
Yeah.
But there's repercussions to that.
Yeah, you also don't understand like what do you,
what, where are you, man?
Like I'm dying over here.
Like, you don't understand what they put me through.
And we went to go see him.
He reached out and said he was on tour with Paul Simon.
At this point, like call me out is like on M.T.V every day,
like that album's blowing up.
It was huge.
Huge.
How did that, did he, was he on the album too?
So he wasn't on the album
because Paul went to South Africa to make the album
but my dad made it possible
for Paul to get into South Africa
and coordinated the musicians for him to work with.
Like, and Paul was making that album in secret
in South Africa, which is crazy.
Also like Paul Simon was a gangster
like a real, a real g.
I'm trying to remember what the state of apartheid
was at that time.
Peak.
Yeah.
Peak like bad.
So he had to do it completely undercover.
On the low.
Wow.
And in exchange, you know,
to acknowledge what my dad did to help facilitate that,
he not only took my father on tour
but he made him a headliner.
He shared, so it was the Graceland tour
and then the headliners were Paul Simon,
Ladysmith Black Mambazo, Miriam Makeba, Hugh Masekela.
Wow.
That is how Paul, that's how every poster was.
That's what the billing was
and the entirety of the show was him storytelling
how important this music was
and then giving them the platform and the stage
to these African artists to shine
like super, super, super progressive.
And he was taking a lot of shit for it.
You know, there were people
who thought he was being exploitative.
I remember being in the press conferences
where, you know, they would try to jump on my father
and be like, you know,
isn't he a culture vulture, et cetera.
My dad would be like, what are you talking about, man?
Like, do you not see what we're doing here?
We're sitting here in this international press conference
and we're talking about South Africa and like,
this is gospel to people to be concerned, to be curious,
to wanna know why
and to start demanding of their governments,
to not like wanna participate in this thing.
And it really, I do believe that that was a huge part
in shifting the world's consciousness about apartheid.
100%, it is complicated though,
because the argument is obvious that,
look here's a white guy, you know,
so he's gonna be the one who's gonna introduce
all these forms of music to the world.
But in truth, that's what he did and he exposed,
he gave a level of exposure to a certain type of music
and provided a cultural lens on, you know,
civil rights and social dilemma that was going on
in a manner that could not have been achieved otherwise.
But he's still a white dude
kind of taken a bunch of black people.
Yeah, and he was gonna take, that he was down.
But they were playing the music.
They were playing the music.
You know,
that's the difference between, you know,
Elvis or the Stones or someone like that.
I mean, they were all playing the music
and my dad had his back.
It was like their relationship was very special.
But anyway, we went to go see that show in New York,
my mother and I and just spend a couple of days with my dad.
And Paul Simon was the one who just said
you should come on the road with us.
And I looked at him and I laughed.
I was like, what?
This is no way my parents like,
he's like, well I think you need to spend some time
with your dad I'm gonna talk to your mother.
And I remember backstage it was like,
I mean, the third night I see Paul
like he talked to me about what he was gonna do.
My dad had told Paul, like there's no way
his mother won't allow, don't even ask.
And I see Paul in the corner, man doing this thing like
just G and my mother loved him.
She's not gonna say no to him.
Yeah, she was like, I saw her nodding
and we went back home to New England.
I remember that fight.
I remember the debate between my mother and stepfather.
I was in my bedroom, like listening with my ear to the door.
I could hear the screaming and I knew my mom had won
like there was a silence.
I didn't hear my stepfather speak anymore.
I was like, this shit might be happening.
And he came by, I was afraid he walked by me
and he said, well, I guess this is what you want
so good luck.
I remember when he drove me to the trains.
Like this air of disappointment.
Total disappointment.
When he drove me to this train station
to go take the plane to New York,
to go get the Amtrak to New York.
It was one of those scenes where it wasn't like
it was silent, it was like, bye.
You know, like he had taken the L with my mom
and I was just like yes.
What an insane life experience.
It was the greatest experience, Rich.
So you were like for three months right on the road?
Yeah, it was like almost famous.
The movie, like, it was kind of, there was a lot like that.
I saw a lot of things that I probably shouldn't have
at 15 and a half, but I also experienced so so much.
I mean, we're playing like 20, 30,000 person venues,
three, four nights in a row sold out.
Wow.
You know, watching my dad
just like destroy, you know, and dad and I are hanging out,
we're playing tennis every day or basketball with Paul.
And there was when we were in Sydney,
we were in Sydney for like a week and a half
and the local crew, you had your roadies
that were from the States and then we'd pick up local crew
in every city.
And one of the guys there had a surf board
and he'd always have it backstaged in the rigging.
I'd walked by it and I was fascinated by it
and I just like, bug him, like, hey, what's that?
And he told me about, I was like, I wanna see that,
like, can I see that?
Can you take me?
And he's like yeah man, yeah man,
I'll take you, I'll take you
and then finds like, I can't take him out,
I'm busy but you know, told me like where to get the ferry
and where I could see it.
So I'd set out one day, took a ferry to Bondai.
And, you know, he told me exactly where to go.
I bought a sandwich at this little sandwich shop
and I sat down on this bench and sure enough, that afternoon
two kids right around my age, come walking by.
They're holding these boards.
I'm like, all right, cool.
And they paddled out ways where maybe like two three feet
and they put on a show.
And the first thing to me, I was like
these kids are breakdancing on water.
This is dancing on water there's this freedom.
I could see the tech, like the expression.
I was a b-boy kid.
So I knew like, you know, there's this step flamboyancy
of like taking a move and making it your own
and I'm like, that's what they're doing on the surf board.
I'm like, I don't know where or how I'm going to do that.
It burnt into my brain.
And then a year later I come home from the tour,
a year later, I come home from school one day
and my stepfather says, sit down.
I'm like, what's up?
This is in April of my junior year high school.
We're moving to California in two weeks,
your mother doesn't wanna be cold anymore.
What are you talking about?
I have a girlfriend.
Like, I finally like figured out how to live here.
What do you mean?
I'm on my third high school as it is.
Right, and you're looking at your senior year.
If you transplant you're gonna start a new school
for your senior year.
For your senior year.
Yeah.
You're gonna finish out the last,
like five weeks in a new school of your junior year
in a new place.
Right.
And there was no point of reference
for what Carlsbad was.
I literally looked up in an encyclopedia.
I was like, got some, like some reference.
There was a famous dirt bike track at the time.
Why did they choose Carlsbad?
Was that a church thing too?
It was a hybrid.
I think they had made like a compromise
between the two of them.
My stepfather again, wanted to like
and the church is very organized
so you could literally like pick where you wanted to go
if you were at that point.
My stepfather was an elder.
Where do they need help?
And my stepfather's aspiration was that
we were gonna go move there
and then we were gonna go serve in a Spanish congregation.
'Cause my was Puerto Rican.
But didn't you get into some trouble in Australia
that caused a little consternation with the church?
I got into trouble in Australia, but I got into,
what caused consternation with the church
wasn't my trip to Australia.
I was young enough and I wasn't baptized yet
so I didn't really talk about the shit
that I'd got into in Australia.
It was a few years later when I was 19,
when I went to South Africa on my dad's tour
on his homecoming tour,
that's what caused the consternation with the church.
Yeah it come clean.
Had to come clean conscience is burning a hole in you
about what you did with.
Not well received.
Not well, I got kicked out.
(Rich laughs)
I got disfellowshipped from the church for.
That's the term disfellowshipped?
Yeah, for about a year.
When no one could talk to me.
That's rough, man.
I had to move out.
Is that your community?
Yeah, I had to move out of my parents' house
otherwise my stepfather
was gonna lose his position in the church.
You were 19?
19.
Yeah.
Wow.
That was a real one.
That was a real one, yeah.
But you moved to Carlsbad.
Moved to Carlsbad
and you know, we wake up in the morning
and you're in this place.
Like when we drove in that night, in the U-Haul
and then that next morning you wake up,
walk out the front door (inhales)
it smells different.
I never smelled this before and look up and like
it feel this air feels different.
Palm trees swaying, and I remember looking
panning right slowly and I recognize that we're on a hill
and about two miles away, a mile or two away is the ocean.
And I'm like, okay, I still don't.
There's no point of reference about surfing.
I'm just taking in where we're at.
And like, literally in that moment at moment
as we're unloading the U-Haul my stepfather and I
like a kid comes driving by in a purple Honda Revo scooter
with a full waterfall haircut, a tank top t-shirt,
board shorts, sandals and a book bag between his legs.
And I'm like, what is that?
That kind of alien?
What did I, like literally it was an alien
and in my mind is like he's going to school?
What?
In a couple of days later I go enroll in this school
and everyone's dressed like that.
And I'm like in literally like in like Timberland boots,
jeans, I've looked like I've come from another planet.
Everyone's speaking in this weird dialect.
And it said, you know, dude, and bro, and bra.
Right, you're like run D.M.C in their Spicoli.
Yeah, exactly.
And I met some cool kids when we went to church,
my mother was genius.
She was like, sure, we'll do your Spanish thing eventually
but we're starting in English.
She also had no intention to ever.
She's crafty.
Yes my mother was crafty, super crafty.
She is like, alright, sure.
But also like the compromised part was like
her alternative medicine crew
was like running heavy in Soquel.
Like she could be amongst her people
and not be aware of it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
North County, San Diego,
she's right where she wants to do that.
Right where she wants to be and she bought
a store, a sight unseen a business from a woman
who was in, worked with like one of the same herb companies
that she she dealt with.
And that was, we were supposed to be moving to a place
that had a storefront.
It turns out that the storefront was literally
the garage of this woman's house in a cul-de-sac
on a hill that had literally no traffic at all.
And there's no like Instagram to promote your business.
(Mabena laughs)
And it was like, oh, well this is different.
My mom, you know, realize like, oh,
I'm gonna have to build up a whole clientele
and it was a whole thing.
And shout out to my stepfather, you know,
for as much as we had a lot of shit that like, you know,
was a challenging relationship on many levels.
He didn't have work and he went out and became a day laborer
to like help make shit work,
like he was out working construction, you know,
on construction sites,
you know, making whatever $15 an hour.
And like, pretending like everything was good.
That's rough.
But it was rough before he was able to like establish
his thing and he started a pest control business
'cause that's what he did back East.
But these kids that I met at church went to my high school
and it turns out they were all surfers.
And a couple of them were like deaf
they weren't like super holy.
They were like, we're cool,
and this kid, Justin, he invited me to lunch
the next day at school and I was so stoked
to meet some kids that were cool.
And you could leave campus to go to lunch
which I had never experienced before the East.
Like we go to school, you're in prison
until it's time to get out.
And we went to this beach parking lot
after we'd gotten food at a place called Carl's Junior
that I didn't know existed.
And we're sitting in the car in the back of his,
I mean in the trunk of his Subaru hatchback with
and the car is packed with everybody,
like, you know, eating.
And they're looking out in the lineup
and I look up, I'm like, ah, no way, surfing.
And these guys are speaking in the language,
talking about what they're seeing waves and swell.
And I'm just sitting there quiet
like what I'm flashing back to a year ago in Bondai.
And I was like, hey, I've seen this before.
And they're like, whatever it did, I'm like, no
I was in a show here last year at Bondai beach
and they're like, now what?
(all laughs)
Pre-internet, like Bondai beach must've been like ass.
Yeah, I've seen it in magazines and movies.
And also mind you, there's like couple of guys.
You got a least likely guys you would ever imagined.
These two other black kids in the school.
One runs track and the other one plays football
and I've shown up.
And they're like, what are you talking about?
And then I'd tell him my story and like, Paul Simon,
my dad, they said like, who are you?
Like, I'm like, I wanna do that.
Like I saw this and I was like, if I ever get a chance,
I told Justin, like I want to try it
and he's like, all right,
be at my house on Saturday.
And that's how I got to experience surfing.
We went there and they had a wetsuit and board for me
and put the wetsuit on backwards, everyone laughed and
Right, whatever was it.
You ended up surfing like 170 days in a row, right?
Without missing a day?
Yeah, I surf.
So you are committed to figure this out.
The first time I stood up was like for five seconds.
And it was literally like,
I had gone to church thousands of times, you know,
prayed in groups, in large conventions
and in our, you know,
our three different religious meetings,
I never ever felt spirituality before.
I'd never felt a soul calling like I did at 16 and a half,
standing on a surf board for like five seconds.
Time stopped, everything changed.
It literally felt like whatever some spirit poured into me.
And when I came up after falling,
I screamed as loud as I could
and my whole life just pivoted
and it was like, okay, this is everything now.
And I'd never, it was.
You heard that clarity.
I heard that clarity,
it was the greatest spiritual awakening
that I could have ever asked for at the time.
Yeah, I mean, we could talk for two hours
about the spirituality of surfing,
but what's interesting is that
it was etched into your soul in a way
that almost makes it sound like
some kind of past life thing.
Like when you have that experience in Bondai
and then when you actually connected with it.
I mean, first of all, you have that experience of Bondai
and there's a knowingness about your path
on some conscious unconscious level.
Then the universe conspires to move you to, you know,
the epic surf spot in America, like completely,
I mean, nobody could have predicted a set of circumstances
that would bring that about,
and then the manner in which you just go all in on it
from the outset, like it's wild.
In retrospect, yeah.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean it just clicked
it was like, oh, this is me.
Everything associated with this.
I need to just soak.
I would go to the library at school
and read back issues of surfer magazine.
Like I had to learn the culture, the origins, everything.
And as you're coming of age
and you're dealing with all the challenges
of your teen anx and then the extra layers
of that were particular to my family
but every kid had a version of it.
Surfing became this mega oasis
for like none of that mattering
like the ultimate freedom of expression, of like
that was the one place that I could express myself wholly
that I couldn't do with my mom and stepdad
and I couldn't even do with my dad,
like surfing literally was that place
where I could just express
even though I had the tensions of a community
that thought they were the definition of the thing
and that they were allowing me to visit in their space
and people many times feeling uninhibited to tell me
that I shouldn't be out there
and using the N word, et cetera, et cetera.
None of that could actually get in the way of the thing.
Like when I stood up to do the thing,
there were no voices except mine.
Wow.
Yeah, meanwhile, your dad is modeling this example
of being fully expressed in his artistic voice.
You have your stepdad and your mom
kind of modeling their version of trying to connect with God
or, you know, being, you know spiritual examples
and you finding your own version of these two things
in a completely unique way
that probably confounded all of them.
Every (all laughs)
You're so accurate, bro, like they were flummoxed.
Right?
My mom, stepdad, dad, aunt, everyone was like
what is happening?
You know, I had a chance to get into a really good school
because my dad's sister is an incredible academic
and she had some relationships and she was a professor
like now we can get him in.
It was a historically black college on the East coast
and I just was like, I have no interest.
What?
Like, my dad, I'm working construction part-time,
I'm cleaning offices at night.
Like I'm doing whatever I can
to like support my shred habit
and my family is just like confused.
Working to live.
I think it's hard for people.
I mean, I'm like little bit older than you,
but it's hard for people to remember or to understand
how different their culture was then than it is now
in the sense that it wasn't a career path.
There was nothing that you could kind of aspire
to do professionally in this world whatsoever.
It was just a habit that you needed to feed, right?
It was a lifestyle and you found ways of supporting yourself
so you could do the thing and that's kind of where it ended.
That's exactly it.
And my whole, everything about me was like
how do I stay close to the thing so that I can grow in it?
And I have plenty of friends who left and went to school
and, you know, put the boards away
and then came home and got good jobs
and their parents had like had some little slush
waiting for them and they got married.
But there's also all those guys that are out in the lineup
that, you know, are doing that thing too, right?
Guys who are like 20 years older and had it for a long time.
And they, you know, life's hard on those dudes.
Yeah, life's hard on those dudes.
But you know, when I would show up at the
I really got into Dawn patrol and I'd get up, you know,
especially when I was in the janitorial business,
I would clean these offices and car dealerships all night
and then I would time it so that I got off
right when the sun was coming up
so I could be first one out, good conditions, empty lineups.
So I'm this young dude who's trying to play catch up,
like I need to surf as much as possible.
I didn't have the convenience to be like, oh,
it's blown out or whatever.
I'm just there out there every day and I'd be out.
So you get the old dogs who they're in this space of like,
well, I don't know how much longer
I'm gonna be getting to do this from here every day.
All right, and they've built their life around the thing
and had the ups and downs with it.
And I'd spend, you know, those mornings, like having coffee
with these old heads and seeing like
there they'd tell their stories and their love
for the thing in the midst of heartbreak, et cetera.
And I was just like
I was so enamored with those guys
'cause they just had no, there was no ego about the thing.
It's like, it's where they needed to be.
And I heard it there was a kinship there
in that surfing for me is like where I needed to be to be.
And so it was just as hard as it is when I look back on it,
like working two, three jobs at a time, et cetera,
that shit was hard.
But like the joy of like,
well, this is what's always waiting for
this is what I've created the space for.
Made it to that it didn't seem weird to me
that also the idea of like, what are you gonna do later?
It was like, there was no later.
Yeah.
There is right now.
And the relationship to doing anything professional
was only in the context of how it could serve the thing
that you wanted to do, which was to serve.
Yeah.
Right.
Which is the inverse of how most people
look at career paths.
Yeah, it was total, that's all it was.
And therefore I worked every job almost under the sun,
bank teller, et cetera, whatever that I could find,
a balance of two or three jobs that could support the space,
I was good.
Do you think that there was a seed of aspiration
underneath that though?
Like, did you think my life, you know,
is gonna lead me in a direction
that's a little bit larger than this or were you just good?
I was good.
I think that going to South Africa
to assistant role manage my dad's homecoming tour
was definitely the thing that made me come home
and start to really like understand my blackness
in this predominantly white world
and like starting to claim my space.
And then there was getting let go from that surf shop.
That was a really like traumatic experience for me
because I didn't know for a couple of months
that that's why I got let go.
They just told me that again.
Right, it's like some other kid who was working there that
His conscious was bothering him.
His conscious was bothering him
and I had gone to school with him
and he felt like he had to tell me so he could live.
And that was when I kind of was at a crossroads
where I was like, I don't know how,
but like, no one is taking this away from me.
I'm going to figure out a way
to remain as close to it as possible.
But it was just really burned in that
like, I'm not going anywhere.
Y'all, aren't gonna take this from me.
Well, I wanna go back to that South Africa trip
'cause we kind of glanced over that.
But that seems like it must've been pretty profound, right?
Like you're, this is basically at the end of apartheid
and Mandela has been released from prison
and your dad does his tour there
to essentially celebrate this changing of the guard.
Yeah.
And you get to meet Mandela,
right?
I do.
He's not president yet for a few more years
but everything about that trip was insane.
Like was new and in many ways startling.
I had experienced various levels of racism in America
but I had never been, I hadn't yet to be in a place
where like it was the systemic part was still present
and accepted as a way of life.
You know, the laws were just starting to come off the books
when I got there, and South Africa was changing
but it was still an apartheid system.
And you know, something as simple
as like greeting a white person in the airport
as you're waiting for your baggage
and them looking at you, like, why are you talking to me?
You know things that I took very much for granted at home
every single person that's working in the airport
or is wearing like a specific jumpsuit
that's either blue or yellow that identifies them
as a worker and they're all black
and everyone else's white.
Like, you know, all these weird things were like,
oh, this is interesting, you know?
But yeah, I got to meet my
on the second day that I was there,
I met my grandfather and my sister.
That I was named after my grandfather
and my dad hadn't seen his father until he had moved there.
He hadn't seen him for 25 years, 30 years.
So it was all new for me.
And like also like getting this now,
coming into this awareness of my South Africanness,
like, oh, this is a part of me
and this is all kind of starting to well up now.
But we were on tour somewhere
and my dad said we were going to a dinner.
He didn't tell me what was going on
but he said it was important I needed to dress well.
And we're there and there's a bunch
of different people there
and people are hanging milling about
and then a door opens and in walks,
you know, Nelson Mandela.
And on this, never forget like
the way he took over the room without saying anything
in the most humble power
that I've ever witnessed in my life.
And he said a cup of hellos to people
then he walked straight up to me
and he said, hello, you must be Selema.
I'm like, wait, what?
And he told me everything about my life up until that point
and how important it must be for me
that I'm getting to have this experience
and how it was going to make a difference
and how happy he was for me,
that this is what I was getting
and that this would be unforgettable.
Yeah.
It's heavy man.
And I realized that my dad
had been talking to Mandela about me.
Yeah, I mean, your dad's rolling deep with Mandela.
He's playing music in South Africa.
This whole country is shifting and you,
you know, kind of, you know, fly home.
You must've been thinking like I can't,
how could you possibly live up to
that type of legacy, right?
You're working part-time jobs, you're living to surf.
Are you starting to think like
I gotta start my shit out or I need to, you know,
I need to like figure out my version of what my dad's doing
or did you just release yourself from any of that pressure?
I had an experience in Durban
where the cops tried to arrest me for surfing.
One of the things that I knew.
They're famous for that there too, right?
There's a lot of black surfers in Durban.
Now.
Yeah.
But then there were not,
like the beach that I was at a few months before
it was a whites only beach.
And from economic standpoint, socioeconomic standpoint,
no black person would have, like,
within that Durban region would have had access to surfing
to even challenge the thing.
So here along comes me
who was just like dying to get to the coast
because I know what North beach is,
I've seen the magazines,
I'm familiar with the Gunston 500 contests
I'm like, I'm gonna get to surf there.
And I was so angry I had to experienced that by that point.
So much crazy shit had taken place, almost died
because we got attacked and chased in our tour bus
by a bunch of like violently racist off the common people
who thought there were too many black people
inside of our story that we had stopped in
to get some provisions as we were driving to the coast
and we were in a big tour bus, et cetera.
And these guys came and chased us
in a pickup truck with guns and bats and knives.
And it was only because of an army convoy
that happened to be making a cross
after they'd thrown their trucks in front of our bus
to pull us over and attack
that we didn't end up in a much worse situation.
And so when we got to Durban,
I was like get me to the ocean.
I had money in my pocket, walked into a surf shop.
I walked into the Spider Murphy surf shop
and I bought a six, three and they were just,
people were just like
and I told them where I was from, et cetera,
and like, okay and I had the cash
but I still didn't realize how strange it might be
my dad warn me.
And you know, the first time when I went to go paddle out
and I came down the elevator and the hotel
was maybe like three blocks from the beach.
Elevator door opened and everyone in the lobby stopped
and looked at me.
And it was like, there was, you know,
people bustling business, et cetera.
It was the guests of the hotel and the black workers.
And I'm just standing there and it's like a standoff.
And I remember being like, do I walk out?
Do I not walk out?
Do I walk out do I not?
It was that much of a moment.
And there was a really nice woman
who was working behind the desk and she smiled at me
and I walk straight towards her.
And as I walked, no one, like
got back to what they were doing.
They just all kind of stopped and looked and turned.
And she said, I see you going surfing today.
I said, yeah, I went to hand her my keys.
She said, have a nice day.
I was like, okay.
And I handed her my key and I have my board
and I'm in my wetsuit and I'm going to walk out
and like everyone's gaze goes with me.
I walk out on the street
and make a right to go walk towards the beach.
And I hear a car literally like stops and it's like,
looking like what?
People are like looking at me.
I finally make my way to the beach.
I jump off the jetty and I get into the water.
There's four kids are about my age
and they may be like 30 yards away
and they're just looking in shock.
They don't say anything, they're just looking.
My heart's beating like
(imitates heart beat)
Waves of maybe about three
or four feet, and I'm like, okay,
I haven't surfed for a couple months
but like, as soon as a wave comes,
you better stand up and catch this thing.
Wave comes, paddle, get to my feet.
Don't fall, new board, the whole thing,
get down the line feeling good
like, okay, should I kick out?
And those kids just went woow.
Crazy.
They paddled at me.
Think kind of a movie?
Yeah, and they're like, who are you?
Where are you from?
What is this?
And now we start talking, you know, I'm telling them
that I live near and I surf Trestles
and they're like, what?
Do you, you know, they know the wave magazines.
And that begins this thing and each day
that I would go down to the beach,
people would mellow out
and they'd still be looking curiously.
But like the people who were working the beach
were starting away about getting to know kids.
On the fourth day, I get there
and I'm about to jump off the jetty
and the waves are bigger.
It's like real North beach,
like cracking out by wall it's on.
And I hear, hey, hey,
don't you know you're committing an illegal act?
And turn around and he was a giant cop.
And he's got his sjambok,
which is like a rubber nightstick,
like a heavy rubber nightstick.
And he's in the backswing
like ready to come down on my head.
And I just scream, I'm like, I'm an American,
I'm an American.
Prove it, prove it to dirty fucking cop, prove it.
I happened to have my passport
in the sleeve of a board bag I bought with the board
and I'm like shaking and I pull it out
and he sees it's American but he's reading my name
Selema Mabena Masekela, his head's freaked out.
And I'm explaining to him why I'm there, et cetera
and he said, we've been watching you.
We've been watching you for three days.
You think you're cute?
You think you can come here and break our laws?
I said, what do you mean break our laws?
They sat four days trying to figure out
how to stop this new South Africa
that they were witnessing from taking place.
And they found an old antiquated law
that says you're not allowed to jump off
of the pier, the jetty to go into the water.
It took them four days to come up with it.
They start to dig up some kind of law
that they can hang it on you.
So they could set a trap.
So as to get you out of there, right?
They had police van blocking the entrance to the jetty
in case I run.
So each day that you're going out to surf
are more and more people showing up
to witness what's going on.
Like, there's a lot of, there's like building tension?
Yeah, there's people like on the peer watching
and taking place like take pictures.
Isn't anybody else surfing out there
or no one's in the lineup?
The people are on lineup, yeah.
Just no black people.
Right.
No black people.
And there was no law anymore
that said a black person couldn't use the beach or surf,
they defined some kind of technicality,
like, you know, hanging the mobsters
on Rico or something, right?
Like they got to do an end run.
Exactly, and that was a massive experience, you know?
But they didn't arrest you.
They didn't, they couldn't.
I had American passport.
And then they figured out who my dad was
and the size and scope of why I was there
and they didn't want an international coincident.
Yeah, it would have caused a major ruckus, right?
But they didn't let me jump off.
They walked me off of the pier
and the people, kids are yelling at them from the water,
leave me alone.
It was a whole thing.
But that was like the, I think the real seed planter.
Have you gone back to Durban since then?
Yeah, yeah, I've surfed there.
Did you find that cop?
I wish I could.
I've been there since I've surfed with all,
there's an organization there now called
Surfers Not Street Children.
And there's just like a plethora of like young black.
Yeah, I remember reading something about that.
Like, there's a pretty robust young black surf culture
in Durban, yeah.
It's a huge scene.
And they still battle the conversation.
You know, a lot of the white surfers
like to call it development surfers
like it's like some sort of charity
and it's like, no, these kids are surfers,
they love this just as much as you,
this is not some sort of like development thing.
Get there they're getting access and the tools
has required assistance, but they're surfers like you are.
And it's slowly, slowly coming around.
Yeah, well, you've got this book
that just came out "AFROSURF"
and I haven't gotten a chance to see the copy.
I should have brought you a copy.
You know what I thought about asking you to bring one
and then I was like, how I'm I gonna ask him to.
That's on me.
But I want that book,
like I saw images of the pages online
and it looks like just an incredibly beautiful book.
Like the photographs in there are stunning.
And this whole idea that the first record of surfing
was in Ghana in 1640, like blew my mind,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
And so it's this whole revisionist history
around surf culture and the origins of surfing.
It really is.
And it's 300 pages of African stories around the ocean
and surfing from various countries,
told from the perspective of the people who live there
and shot written by the people who live there,
shot by the photographers.
Like, if I say like, if it wasn't for COVID,
we probably would have done the book very wrong.
You know what I mean.
Would have like gotten like some great
sort of head photographer, creative person to go
and like on these journeys and liaison with these people
but like we would have done it
but it wouldn't have been the right kind of right.
Right, she's getting the boots on the ground,
people that actually are members of that community
to document it for you, right?
We put together sort of a template, you know
because of social media
we had built great relationships
with a bunch of different people
around the various countries
as surfing has really started to explode on the continent.
And it's like, okay, we're gonna redefine this idea,
the lens of the definition of what surf culture is,
because the idea of it being primarily
from this Southern California and South Australian lens
predominantly, it just,
there's just a such a massive landscape
and we're not telling the stories.
Right, when was it first originally discovered
to start going down in Hawaii?
'Cause that's the lower right?
Yeah.
That's the conventional wisdom.
I think it's like it's Cook, is it?
When Captain Cook arrived and he saw people, yeah.
It's Cook like I think in the 1700's,
yeah, late 1700's.
And what's interesting about that, right,
is that like you have missionaries
like doing everything they can
to like stomp out this, you know, half nakedness
and people like, you know, dancing on water
and topless, et cetera.
And then it being, you know sort of taken
and the story becoming that it's like a So-Cal thing.
You know, I mean--
Yeah, whitewashing the indigenous roots out of the hole--
Out of the conversation, I mean
people don't realize I do come to my uncle was like,
he was out spreading the gospel
like showing people and teaching people the thing.
He went all over the world to do so,
but he didn't die like a rich man, you know,
he was less celebrated than people think,
it was much later that he got the bust, et cetera
and we, like we came to revere what he did
and there was definitely a bit of like an assuming
and taking over of the idea of the culture
and which because of like all the other inherent problems
and histories of especially in America
when it comes to black people in the ocean,
it's very easy for people to think like,
oh, black and brown people don't like,
that's not where they play.
Right it's very, when I--
So you've know how to swim.
When I first told the kid at school
that I was going to learn to surf, he looked at me,
he was like, but bro,
you people don't even know how to swim dude,
like what do you mean you're gonna learn to surf.
And he was concerned for me.
Like, don't you know?
That was coming from a good place.
Yeah like a P.S.A.
(all laughs)
Wow.
And you know
I had a very, very, well-known extremely talented
iconic surfer, not too long ago.
Tell me like, well, you know
surfing doesn't have any responsibility
towards like expanding the landscape
because you know, you're not you
and the few like you on a nominally
but it's like not a part of black culture.
I'm like, do you not know?
Or have any clue the manner
in which this country worked very very hard
to make people think that like they're living in the areas
that they do, where no one else lives.
It doesn't look like them is because of hard work.
Like, do you not understand the history of red lining?
Do you not understand that they used to take dogs
to the beaches in California, in Florida, in the Gulf
and chase black people off the beaches?
Like that's part of our legacy.
That story that is just coming out now
about Manhattan Beach and--
Racist beach.
Right, yeah, yeah, explain that
'cause that's super interesting.
And it's about reparations.
It is, it literally is a classic example of reparations
where you had this black family, the Bruce family
that were like yo, Manhattan Beach, dope.
Let's settle here, let's start businesses here
let's make an Oasis where black people feel like
we have a piece of this ocean lifestyle and culture.
This is also us.
All right, and for people that are listening
who aren't familiar, Manhattan Beach,
I guess technically it's part of L.A, but it's really not.
It's a true beach community
that's South of Los Angeles.
And when you're there, it's like, it's a world unto itself.
And it's also extremely white.
Very, very, 97% white and very well off
and it's a lifestyle.
You drive through Manhattan Beach and you're like--
You don't go anywhere else in L.A
people who live there that's their world.
Why would you?
Like what are we gonna get on a freeway
like, do you see how we're living?
It is amazing.
It's a place that you drive through
and you're like, I want this, this is awesome.
And there were historical bleep.
There were black people and the black family especially
who were like, yes, we want to live this life too.
And people worked very, very hard to make sure that
their businesses were challenged, that they were burned.
They did everything they could.
But a lot of those black families
they bought up a bunch of real estate, right?
So they had some Primo real estate, just like a beach club
and it was very much, you know,
there was a black culture thing going on
in Manhattan Beach at this time.
Yeah, and it was rocking
and a strong majority of white people were like, nah,
they can't live like us.
So we're gonna do whatever we can to shut this shit down.
You know, torn, you know, burn businesses,
get people to boycott you name it
until finally they convinced the city to just take the land,
take it and kick them out.
Yeah, it was like an eminent domain thing.
Yeah, and that's literally like
where the lifeguard station is today.
Right, so now the issue has come up recently
because there's an initiative, I don't know.
You probably know where it's at
I'm not sure where it's at right now
to basically make reparations to that family
who had their land taken from them
to build that lifeguard station.
Yeah, to essentially either give the lease money
to them to the family, figure out
what giving some of the land back is.
But the idea that the city has proposed it is huge.
Right, I mean, it's huge in and of itself,
but it also sets in motion a precedent
for how to handle future, you know,
or other incidents that are similar to this
of which there I'm sure
there's hundreds of thousands, right?
There's probably unlimited examples of this kind of thing.
And it's very easy for people I think in this country
who have been the beneficiaries of a really shitty education
that we made sure to filter out
a lot of how we've come about
and a lot of why we do have these broad gaps
between the races in America.
It's very easy for people who don't know any of this
to be like, well, you know, you just gotta work hard.
You know, my family worked hard and we did this
and why are we still talking about this?
I don't see color.
It was very easy for you to not see color
if you don't know the history.
And if when you come into the knowledge
of these darker parts of our history,
if when you come into that knowledge,
your first reaction is to look the other way
and double down.
I'm sorry for you.
But like you being uncomfortable added
and wanting to think that it's a myth
doesn't mean that it's gonna go away.
And until we just accept and come to grips with it, like
and make sure that like that's teachable
so that we don't go back to it
and we can get to a point of real equality.
We're gonna continue to run through this cycle
because people are gonna feel threatened, right?
At the idea of equality meaning I'm going to lose something.
Right, it's that zero sum game perspective.
And there's a lot of fear around that.
People don't wanna be challenged in their worldview
or their assumptions about where they fit in this equation
if it means that they have to reckon with something
that they've never really had to look at.
Yeah, and in the last year, you know,
I've had a lot of people,
a lot of businesses reach out to me to be like,
hey, how do we have this conversation?
And, you know, it's getting people to understand
they're like it's uncomfortable.
And it being uncomfortable is a good thing, you know,
be okay with like the fact that this is uncomfortable
because if we can be all be uncomfortable together
then we actually get to move forward.
Right, but a lot of black people like yourself
who wield influence in certain subcultures
are getting those phone calls right now from brands saying,
help me through this.
What are we supposed to say?
What are we supposed to do, right?
Yeah.
You know, and you're like,
oh, okay, now, you know,
now you want me to be your marketing department.
Right, and it's, I mean the way my phone was ringing off.
(Rich laughs)
I can imagine.
I had to turn my phone off at a certain point.
And you're having--
You are the one guy in surfing,
like they're all gonna call you, right?
Yeah, and there are others who came, you know,
I got to say, they're--
I guess this is better they're calling you,
they're not calling you.
Yeah.
But it put you in a weird situation.
A very weird situation and me being like--
It's not your responsibility
how they message their customer base and community.
And me being like I'm happy
that you have decided to come into this awareness.
Also, there's a link in my bio of a whole toolkit
of books, movies, and things you should watch
and digest before we're gonna have a conversation.
And then if you wanna have a conversation with me
as far as your business is concerned
and your intentions are actually like to change culture
then we can figure out a way to engage in exchange
because doing this kind of work
that is not like I don't wake up in the morning
and want to talk about race.
Not that I want to wake up in the morning
and like go enjoy life and pursue my passions
like everyone else.
And it's a real, it requires a lot of mining of shit
that is uncomfortable and is pain,
not even uncomfortable, it's painful
to get other people up to speed.
So I just said, you know,
you gotta be willing to do the work.
And also realize like this isn't a box that you're checking.
It's not like if you could do this, this, this, and this,
you're good.
Do you, as a person want to live in an energy
that is anti-racist.
Are you down for that as like, yes, I think that's who I am.
If you're down to work at what that is and what that means
realize that it's work that you're gonna be doing
for the rest of your life,
but it can be joyful and pleasant
because you are doing the right thing to
you literally making the choice to be like
I'm going to live my life
in a direction of being anti racist,
is literally saying I'm going to help change the world.
And when I think when people realize
that it's a life switch,
then it becomes far more sobering
'cause they realize like, oh, this
I'm gonna be, you know, I'm gonna be learning about this
for the rest of my life?
I'm like, yeah,
that's what we're talking about here.
Yeah, man, it's heavy.
It is, it is heavy.
And it's heavy in that like,
there are these just insidious forces
that for whatever reason,
they're within the agenda politically
like can just come through with like a giant flamethrower
and just be like,
(imitates the sound of flamethrower)
And just gaslit the whole thing.
Mute it out.
Just mute it on out and you're like fuck.
All right, you know, like the last four years
of what we dealt with was insane to have though.
I don't think people realize what it was like
to have the largest voice in the known world
be able to be like all this stuff that is being said,
it's not a thing.
You make sure that you be American
like, you know how to be American.
To have like the most powerful voice in the world,
very codedly reinforcing and making it your right
to engage in bad behavior because it makes you feel better
and helps you to cloak your fear.
I was--
Yeah, but that kind of permission slip
also gave rise to the conflicts that we've seen
and the civil rights uprising
that was incident to that, right?
Which just brought all of this out into the open
for us to discuss
and whether we're gonna see our way through it
to a better, more, you know,
habitable space for all of us remains to be seen.
Yeah.
I mean, right now, the Derek Shovan trial's going on,
I'm actually going to,
we're going to Minneapolis next week.
There's some interviews there.
I'm gonna interview the mayor and a couple other folks.
Wow.
So we're gonna be there.
I don't know when the trial is gonna end
but that city is ready to blow.
And I think whatever happens there is gonna
tell the tale in terms of what's gonna happen next.
You saying that just gave me such chills
'cause I was sitting at home last week.
I watched a little bit of it,
but it's too traumatic for me to watch,
like, to really sit in.
And I thought to myself, like,
if this thing goes the wrong way,
I couldn't even begin.
Yeah.
I can't--
I think it's a good chance
it's not gonna go the right way.
Yeah.
A heartbreak wouldn't even be the,
I don't know what I would have left.
Like I honestly like that's one of those things
where I'm like, I've been through so many of these,
you know, where you're like, is this the one time
where we're going to get actual, the justice advertised
that we have in this country?
Like the advertised version of like, well, you know,
let our incredible justice handle it.
And if
ah, yeah, I can't even begin to comprehend
what that would be.
It literally, like it hits me in places within my body
that I didn't even know I could register.
Yeah.
You know.
That kind of like, fuck.
Time will tell something's gonna happen.
I hope not, I also like, I'm just like,
I mean, I know what this country is built on,
we know the history, but I'm like
for the people who really like hold on to this idea
of supremacy or hold onto this idea that like,
in order to be an American,
if you're not a white Christian male,
we're gonna need you to walk as closely
to what that looks and feels like
in order to be accepted, in order to be an American.
This is the lens of what an American is.
And if you can't figure out how to walk
to as close to those, imagine guidelines,
then we're at an impasse.
There are people who wake up every day
and that's their goal, that's their charge
with an idea that like, yes, my whiteness
and my inherent Christianity
that I believe this country is founded on,
gives me the right to dictate
how everyone else should be and live.
And you're not gonna tell me about what happened wrong
to get here, because that doesn't matter
because, you know,(imitates sound of flamethrower)
Flame throw it.
This is the greatest country in the world
and nothing's going to change that.
Well, the greatest country in the world
is also immensely flawed.
And I don't care who you pray to.
That's a fact.
And until we collectively get into the business
of wanting to move forward together,
we're just gonna, it's asinine.
Well, I think we're at a crossroads with all of this
and I vacillate between, you know,
kind of the pessimistic sentiment that you just expressed
and you know, a sense of hope and optimism.
You know, I do see diverse voices
making an impact in the world.
I see these subcultures opening up in interesting ways
perhaps not as quickly as it should
or not in a manner that is being as welcomed
as one would like, but I do see change happening.
I mean, how do you know when you think of surfing,
you know, where are we in terms of diversity
or you know, inclusion?
Like I remember who is the woman, I think she's Australian
who, before she passed, yeah,
had the black lives matter board
and that caused quite a ruckus, right?
Like a lot of people weren't happy with that.
But you know, that's a bad-ass move.
It was a power move.
Yeah.
And I love that it was a woman that chose to do so
and was the first voice.
Yeah, it's like a cabarnet kind of move.
Yeah, and that it took, you know--
Explain what she did for people that don't know.
So Tyler Wright, two-time world champion
in the midst of COVID as Australia was getting more open,
they decided to run a couple of events there
for Australian professionals.
And it was her first time back to competition.
In a long time, she'd been dealing with
an auto-immune disease that had a very, very,
like whatever long COVID is,
she had like the most extreme version
of what a long COVID would be,
where her body just would not reset.
She had to do a lot of work
and she basically was out of the water for almost two years.
And first event back to compete,
she shows up at the beach.
Two time world champion, one of the faces of the sport.
Right, white check.
White check with her, the bottom of her surfboard says
black lives matter.
And she sits and kneels on the beach for
it wasn't eight minutes and 46 seconds,
but it was nine minutes and change.
She tied it to indigenous murders in Australia
of indigenous and Aboriginal people
who have been murdered by the police.
Like that was the number of people
and it was nine minutes and change that she knelt
with her fist in the air,
with a boy that said black lives matter.
Then she paddled out, mind you a heat is only 30 minutes.
She paddled out and she smoked her competitors.
So she conceded literally a third of her time.
A third of her time, and then went out there
and just crushed the other two women
who were in the heat.
And Surfer Magazine and Stab and the Inertia
and all the platforms, you know, posted this photo
and the comment sections.
It was the level of vitriol and hate.
And clearly like, let's face it hate is just fear, right?
It's just really well cloaked up fear.
People were so terrified by the act of this young woman
who was like, body is barely there in recovery,
like making this stand.
You could go look in the comments today
and you'll just be blown away.
And I think that was the craziest part was like
there's no place for this in surfing
and we don't see color here.
And like all of the, like the panic, you know,
knee jerk response, it's like, ah,
I can't believe this is happening here,
but you signaling, like all of the shit that I've met
I actually feel bad for those types of people
like if that's where it comes from for you.
But the hardest part was seeing people that you know
within that being so, so, so, so triggered.
And it was definitely one of those things where I was like
I've been trying to tell y'all
because I've obviously been very, very vocal
about this specifically in our community in the last year.
But that was a moment where I was like,
sips the tea you know.
(Rich laughs)
Pinky out.
Pinky out, like, dude we have a problem here.
And the--
So how did the world of surfing reckon with that
and the aftermath?
They are reckoning, you know, reckoning as long,
it was only like maybe six, seven months ago.
But I see it at least at a brand level
and within the platforms.
You know the platforms are opening up and learning that,
you know, this for so long the culture of surfing
has been through the lens of professional surfing,
which is like 60 people that are the best in the world,
men and women, like going around the world
and surfing at the highest level.
The idea that like surf culture
has to be about that aspiration to touch that
solely is crazy.
Like surfing is so much bigger than that.
And I think that the brands and the platforms
are starting to realize like, oh,
there's actually more audience.
There is an upside to us here
as far as engagement and economically
to expand different storytelling
and reach out to different audiences for what this thing is.
Yeah, it's not only the right thing to do.
It's in their economic self interest.
(Rich laughs)
And for me, I'm like, yo, if it being good business
is your starting point, okay.
I wish that that's not what it has to be, but like cool
that gets us on the road.
And I'm seeing a lot of hopeful potential
for what this can be.
And the younger generation is also like,
well, I have no time for this like, what's happening here?
Yeah, and also it's really just a matter of time
until they inherit the whole situation.
And, you know, my inclination is that
it's gonna be a lot better when that happens.
I agree, and there's also like, because of social media,
you have all of these different marginalized groups
that have like been like, oh,
I'm not gonna wait for you all to tell my story.
We're gonna tell our stories, you know?
And so you have like all these great groups
throughout the entire landscape of the outdoors
who are like this is how we live the thing.
And now it's just so cool to see that
I see it in surfing, you know,
there's this really, really great group of women
called Textured Waves.
I never thought that I would see surfing told
through the lens of like black women specifically.
And if you go and you look up Textured Waves
like you get the coolest, new, beautiful
like just a different end of the thing
that you can't help but be inspired by no matter who you are
and what place you come from.
All right.
You know, and it's across the landscape of snowboarding,
mountain biking, just the outdoors and adventuring
and people learning that these spaces were
purposefully cut off to people of color.
Like it was the last sort of safety barrier
in the wake of segregation, where they were like,
we're losing everything to this integration.
Ah, the outdoors.
Keep them off the beaches.
Let's keep them off the beaches and out of the mountains,
at least we'll have that.
We'll make these elite spaces.
And we're finally at a point where people are like,
not anymore, not anymore.
We've been almost two hours.
We haven't even talked about, oh,
I don't think I said the word X Games yet.
(Mabena laughs)
We haven't even talked about your career.
This is awesome now, you know it was cool 'cause,
yeah, I thought, oh, we're gonna, you know,
kind of walk us, we're gonna walk through step-by-step
all these cool things that you've done
but we had a much more interesting conversation, I think.
Yeah.
Cause we're still at
you busted tables in chronology.
(Mabena laughs)
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
We got time though.
I mean, I do wanna tell the story of how
you kind of, you know, had your kind of breakthrough moment
that led to this amazing career that you've had.
And it goes back to the people pleasing thing, right?
And this sense of, you know, this sort of lack of self-worth
that you battle with.
Yeah, you're speaking of when I got
kind of got the break at E.S.P.N.
Well, even before that, like the first gig
'cause when you're busing, yeah, when you're busing tables
and you got the guy gave you the card, did you call the guy.
Yeah, so I was busing tables
at a place called the Potato Shack in Encinitas.
And that was such a good gig.
Saturday, Sunday morning, you know,
get there like six work till noon, one o'clock
and guarantee go home with like $300.
Like it was, there was never not align
for like 45 minutes and you're just turning them burn
and turn it and burn it and just leave with cash
that's the best.
And one day I was there one morning and this table came
and they all had badges was actually midweek.
They all had badges for the ASR Tradeshow
which was the action sports retailers show that took place
at the convention center in San Diego
which is where all the shops and all the businesses
all around the country and on the Royal would come
to like see new product, write orders, et cetera, big deal.
We'd heard about it, but never got inside.
And now I hear about these kids,
these people around my age that are like, have these badges.
And I told my friend, I was like,
you gotta give me that table.
Greg Whipple, volleyball player, Canadian.
I'm like Whipple, you got to give me the table.
He's like, no way.
I said, I'll give you five bucks for that table.
It's like, you gave me five bucks for that table?
I'm like, yes, dude, just stop talking.
Yes, I know, all right cool.
See this is where I see, this is the ambition.
Like, you're like, yeah, I just wanna live my life.
But now, there's something more inside of you.
Yeah, I knew that those were my people
I just wanted to, I wanted to know who they were
like they were around my age,
like they clearly were in the industry.
I'll put five to $5 down to see what that is
and style them out, coffees for you, orange juice,
refills, et cetera.
They were really stoked.
They were on their way to the tradeshow.
And the one guy started coming back on a regular basis
and we started talking and finally, he just said,
what are you doing with your life?
And I was like, what do you mean?
Like was like, what are you doing?
I was like, oh, you know, I just do what I can to shred.
You know, I work here.
I was working at the Belly Up Tavern in Solana Beach
at night as well.
Things are going decent.
And he said, you're too talented.
Like every time I talk to you, man,
I'm just like blown away.
I see the way you deal with people.
And you know, you can't do this forever.
And it was a kind of abrasive,
but it was hearing that kind of truth
from like someone your own age
and not your parents that stinks.
You're like, ah, I thought like, I thought I was cool.
You need those guys.
You need those guys to give it to you in that way.
And he took out his card and he said, call me.
He worked at Transworld he worked in advertising.
And Transworld for people that don't know
basically publication house
for all these action, sports magazines.
Bible of the sport.
It was the internet of snowboarding and skateboarding
like the global Bible.
And he said, we're looking for a junior ad sales rep
and I would like to take you under my wing and train you.
Like you're built for this.
And I was like, what gives me his card call me.
Living with three or four guys in Cardiff at the time,
show them the card, they are like no way.
I'm like, dude, this guy was giving me a job.
I didn't call him for like three days.
Yeah he told you he'd call you,
call him the next day, right?
I call him like three days, I was scared.
My roommates were like, did you call that dude?
I'm like, what are you doing?
Call him.
Finally call him and his name is Chad DiNenna.
I call him, and he's like,
I told you to call me three days ago, man,
we hired somebody already, you blew it.
Like literally he's like you blew it.
Sorry, click crushed.
I sat at my phone and I cried.
It was like why.
Heavy lesson.
Heavy lesson, heavy lesson.
And then he calls me back two days later.
Our receptionist mind you junior ad sales rep under,
and this guy's writing paper and industry's booming
it's like 93, 94 finished she's booming.
Calls me said the receptionist
is decided to go back to school and I can get you in
you know, the rest is gonna be up to you.
You come in here, you work hard,
you ask people if they need help.
You start here and if you really like,
if you have what I think you do
you'll figure out a way.
And so I took a job there making like 650 an hour
answering phones, but it was literally being,
I was the first person that you engaged with.
I see you know, everything that was incoming.
Everything that was incoming came through me.
Every call, if you wanted to talk to
Grant Brittain famous scape photographer.
If you wanted to talk to John Foster,
the snowboard photographer
if you wanted to talk to advertise, whoever it was
you want to talk to sales, depart everyone
everything came through me.
And that's how I learned the lay of the land.
And then when there was downtime,
I would go and I'd go to the editorial department,
I'd go to the advertising department.
What do you guys need done?
What do you need, what can I do?
And they're like, huh?
Give me a task, whatever, definitely envelopes
whatever it took.
And I just got to build a reputation to the point
where like people would be walking by at lunch and be like,
you want to come to lunch with us?
Be like, yeah.
You know, now you're with like Dave Swift
and escape photographers.
And you're just sitting and like
I started to build relationships.
And then after like four or five months,
people started like kind of fighting
for who got to use me for stuff.
And then I got a job in the sales department
literally selling the magazines to the shops on the phone
and selling like the Transworld merge that went through it.
Right, so you're ground zero,
you know all that new products.
All new products.
You know what the trends are,
what's cool, what's happening.
And I'm now I'm calling shops on the East coast,
in the Midwest, in the Southeast
all through California, et cetera.
I'm telling them what's going on.
What I'm hearing buzzing around.
What's coming on in a new magazine.
Who's riding for who now, et cetera.
They're in turn explaining to me how their region works
and what's cool, et cetera.
Someone says, they're looking for a rider in some place.
I'm like, oh, it's such an such and such
at exit Real-world in Oregon and they've got a kid.
And I became, I used what I learned at the front desk there.
And then that led to leaving and going to work
at Planet Earth Skateboards under Chris Miller
selling skateboards and clothing
to those same shops that I was hustling magazines
and beanies and transport sweatshirts to at Transworld.
And that guy Chad at Transworld,
is that the guy who ended up founding Nixon watches?
Yeah, he founded Nixon watches.
And he's my, one of my best friends
and brothers to this day, almost 30 years later.
So when does the speaking, hosting, commentating thing
start to happen?
The speaking thing starts at Transworld.
There was an event that they were doing called boarded
while I was still actually the receptionist.
Yeah, it was cause that was receptionist actually
for more like about a year.
And they were doing this event called boarded
where it was like an H.I.V awareness event
with music and snowboarding and skateboarding
and they would do it up at big bands were gonna play,
there'd be booths, educational booths, et cetera,
teaching kids about H.I.V awareness, et cetera.
Like this is a real aggressive, very progressive deal.
And I heard the woman Louise Bama who ran production
for events at Transworld was like frustrated
that they couldn't find an M.C.
She was near my desk and I was like, I could do it.
And everyone just stopped and looked like,
first of all why are you speaking
when the grownups are talking?
And then Louise being like, hmm, maybe.
And then she was like, you really think you can do it?
I was like, absolutely the ways I could do it.
And that was my first job speaking.
It was introducing the bands that day and like--
Right.
Giving the run of the land
I got basically hosted a music festival
we could be talking shit.
Right, but the level of certainty and kind of confidence
that you had around that is interesting.
It's similar to how surfing clicked for you initially.
Like there was like this knowing like, oh, I got this
like I can do this thing.
I know you'd never done it before.
I mean, you're on the phone with people all day long
you're talking to people.
I'm on the phone with people all day long.
I grew up with a massive class of my father
in speaking, in storytelling plus in the church,
I had to learn how to reason with people at their doors
to convince them that me being there
was going to change their life.
(Rich laughs)
Right.
As well as get up in front
on stage every few months or so,
and give like an oratory presentation to the congregation
and convince them
that I had just imparted some knowledge to them
or some perspective on scripture.
So you like that intersection of that like crazy,
like theocratic, like we had a book, literally
it was called "Reasoning From the Scriptures."
Like I had to learn how to reason with people
and win argument through healthy exchange
as well as like, you know, being around like my dad
who was a master of it.
Those two things fuse together.
When I started like actually getting to talk to people
for a living, I was like, oh, this is what I know how to do.
Which actually started when I was my the beta for that
was being a teller at Bank of America.
(all laughs)
Deal with a lot of unhappy people, right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
Well, it's also a right place, right time thing too,
because the action sports world
is just kind of coming online.
It's growing like crazy and you know
the X Games hadn't become a thing.
No the only people who cared about it
were the people who did it.
Right.
But Madison Avenue had just realized like, wait
there's hundreds and thousands, if not millions of kids
in this country that care about this thing
and it's only happening within that space
to the extreme burgers and you name it.
And all of a sudden, like what you could only watch
on public access TV, like now people are scrambling
to build content, the extreme games are born, right?
And then, you know, M.T.V starts doing stuff.
And from that first event that I did at boarded
people started to call me to like, you know,
come and announce demos at their shops or they're like
get on the mic.
We'd all take turns in these
endemically built events anyway, like on the microphone.
So I would just be one of the people who--
Right, it was just a side hustle
that you were doing for fun and essentially for free.
And you know, leaf tickets and flight.
Leaf ticket, shop credit.
Right.
You know, you wanted to be at these events anyway.
And when it is where you wanted to
I wanted to be around the shop all the time.
So suddenly it was like skate surf
you know I had like this in
to like be front of the line at these things.
Yeah.
And that's really what led to getting
eventually a break at television.
Yeah, I like how you just embraced it.
You were kind of doing it for the passion.
Did you have a sense that it would lead somewhere else?
Absolutely not.
Right.
You know, there is a kind of look everybody
should be compensated for their skills
and be remunerated for work that they do.
But there's something powerful to be said for, you know
just putting yourself out there
and like doing a lot of shit for free for a long time,
until you get good at it when the stakes are low.
That was the entirety of my career.
Was volunteering, putting myself out there,
doing shit for free
and learning from people who like knew how to do it.
Right, but at some point then you gotta,
you know, know your value, right?
And like, when you start transitioning out of,
hey, I'm no longer your free guy, I gotta pay the rent.
Yeah.
Right, becomes tricky
especially if you're a people pleaser or you feel like
you know, you're the guy
who when you get the business card,
you're not gonna call the guy back.
Rich it is way too insightful.
Well, it's cause I relate.
I'm like, you know, I'm the same guy in a lot of ways.
Yeah, it was that for me.
Even after, you know what?
When I got my break at the E.S.P.N,
I had gone on to start a brand, a clothing company
with my with a bunch of friends called Alphanumeric.
That was a very impactful
sort of birth of the streetwear movement.
We were the first black and brown owned
founded clothing brand in the space.
We had a partnership of a bigger governmental brand
that like funded us,
but it was all run by a bunch of young black and brown kids
and we made waves like really impacted the industry heavily.
And it was such a cool thing after like kind of, you know,
working hard to find my way I jumped around
at different companies and people would be like,
what does he do?
Like, I know he can sell et cetera
but like what are you, what you can, and he's happy.
He's the guy that you're happy to be around,
but like what can he do, you know?
And so starting that brand was like, here's what I can do.
And we're making a difference.
And I was at an event with my team of athletes
I was the team manager marketing guy
and we're in Colorado and a guy walked up to me
after the first day of competition of the events,
triple crown of snowboarding, he said,
are you Sal Masekela?
And I said, yeah.
And he said, my name is Phil Orlins.
I'm the producer of snowboarding from the E.S.P.N X Games
and I'm looking for you.
And I laughed at, I stood up in my bar stool
and I minded that it's raging proposed day one,
everyones at the bar.
And I'm like, whoever having put this guy up to this,
like real funny.
And I threw up the bird, I sat back down.
The guy tapped me on the shoulder again
and he's like, now he's got the in E.S.P.N card is like,
no, I mean and I'm like, and that was
he had seen me in a documentary called Snow Taxi.
And I had also done some stuff at that point
a couple of like, one-offs at M.T.V,
there sports and music festivals.
And this little public access show called Planet X
that was basically my start,
which came from a guy not being there
to interview Tony Hawk at the board event.
And the guy coming up to the stage and be like,
hey, do you know Tony Hawk?
Can you interview him for me?
And that was the start.
And he sat down with me and told me
that they wanted to get real voices at the E.S.P.N
that could actually commentate the culture and the sports
'cause they had been using stick and ball
like broadcast people and it was not translating.
Right, yeah, the community is not responding.
Not responding at all.
We watched it with the volume of I thought it was horrible.
You were stoked to see your friends competing,
but like, oh, when's this gonna just go away
was how we looked at the X Games.
And I just kind of told them everything
that I thought sucked about the X Games.
I said nothing positive for like three hours
over a six pack.
And then when I flew home--
Did you realize it was a job interview
or you just thought you're giving them feedback?
I was giving him feedback and then he did make an offer
and I was like, I don't think I'd wanna do it.
Like I just was like, this is what I'm doing and--
Your life has a string of like not being aware enough
to know what the fuck is going on.
You're constantly getting these opportunities
and you're blind to the truth of them.
I said, no.
Yeah.
And I flew home and I sat with my team.
I go to go to the office at Alphanumeric
and giving them the rundown of the weekend
at the Vans Triple Crown and then I'm like, oh, yeah,
and then there was this dude who, you know,
he wanted me to do for some X Games
and he told me he wanted me to come on
and be a sideline reporter in a few weeks at Crested Butte.
And they're like, what'd you tell him?
I was like, tell him I wasn't really interested.
My friends are like, what are you talking about?
Like, what are you actually, everybody was like, what?
I was like, well, we know we're doing this thing
and we're, you know, the brand, blah, blah, blah and like.
And they were like, you going there
and being a part of the thing
could actually be a representation of the culture
that they need.
Right, you can't complain about E.S.P.N getting it wrong
if you're giving them the you know,
giving them a high hand when they're trying to enlist you.
Yeah, and I also like, but I also just like,
what do you mean me?
I'm gonna go there and make a difference.
Like it's E.S.P.N.
And they put their foot lovingly square between my cheeks
made me call the dude.
He actually called me back a couple of days later
and said, have you thought about it?
And I was like, you know, all right, I'll come.
Then they had another guy call and negotiate with me.
And I hadn't really been paid for television yet.
Like M.T.V I had made it a little bit of money
but you--
They don't pay.
Like, you'd go and do the thing for
you'd be at an event for like 10 days
and they give you like maybe a thousand dollars
you are like yes, a thousand dollars.
And same thing with that first E.S.P.N.
Like X Games, like if I was there for two weeks
they were gonna give you 1500 bucks.
Wow.
And I said, yes.
And this guy, Jamie Reynolds really took an interest in me
and groom me.
And they put me on the sidelines at Halfpipe and Big Air.
And suddenly like these guys who hadn't
men and women who hadn't really been opening up
in their interviews, they get down to the bottom
and here's the homie and I'm asking them questions.
You got history with everybody.
And it was just like, it clicked.
I had a blast, I also was thoroughly unprofessional,
knew nothing about like how to be a broadcaster,
no journalism rules or anything.
I'm of the people.
I'm of the thing and I'm talking to the people at home
that do it.
But they saw something in me that said, like
we might be able to actually like mine this kid.
And that was the beginning of it.
And then 13 years of that.
13 years.
All right.
Two years later, I am the lead play by play person
for skateboarding and snowboarding
and then they made me the overall host of the X Games.
I had a 13 year paid television, broadcasting
journalism education at the worldwide theater.
Right, while you're literally right front and center
when Tony Hawk does his 900
and Shaun White does what he does and all the kind
of craziness that ensued as that entire world
just exploded, yeah.
I was standing on the vert ramp when Tony did the 900.
Wow, wow.
He'll never, ever, ever forget it.
Yeah.
And it's, yeah, within about a year it was like
melted but about a year and a half,
it was like, oh, this might be my thing.
Took you that long to figure that out.
Oh, and almost blew it many times.
Yeah.
Oh absolutely.
(all laughs)
Many times Rich.
Well, I think you found your lane
I mean, then you went on you did the Sochi Olympics, right?
You did world cup in South Africa in 2010.
Yeah, yeah.
You've done tons of stuff with N.B.C sports
this Viceland show.
Yeah, the Viceland show was like a real,
that was the--
Why are you not continue.
Vice World of Sports was, I was my baby.
That was like, I wanted to get
into like real docu storytelling
of culture and people through sports.
Right, so essentially you're going to these
really interesting places, immersing yourself
in the sport and the culture
and the relationship of sport to that specific culture?
Exactly, you're in a remote fishing village in Ghana.
It's like if Anthony Bourdain was an athlete.
Essentially.
Yeah.
And it's funny that you mentioned him
because he was my touchstone like that's I was like,
I wanna do a show that is the Bourdain, but it's sports.
That's not like it's not, you know, real sports on H.B.O
where like, it comes back into the studio
and like someone rules on whether or not
we should be talking about this.
Like I wanna go and have people feel like
we went to this place and Vice gave me that opportunity.
But they, instead of like putting that show on H.B.O,
they launched Viceland and they had been primarily
a digital space that was killing it, right?
Like it's a place where you got to go get real news
and get inserted into the world.
And now they wanted to make the leap to television
and instead of like selling that show to a network
we're launching up, we've done all this,
we can launch a network.
And they didn't really have like a long-term
real big kids plan for what that network was gonna be.
And they also went through a bunch of like challenges
as far as how they ran the business,
they got exposed, et cetera.
And anyway, long story short,
we got canceled after two seasons, but that's the two best
it's the making that show for three years
is the the greatest thing that I've ever gotten to do
'cause it was the best.
Better than being in point break the remake.
(Mabena laughs)
Come on, man.
Let's go to the highlight.
Well, I mean, a week in--
That is history.
A week in Brindisi, Italy,
pretending to be in Tahiti
with the greatest surfers on earth.
It's called acting.
Was awesome.
And I wasn't supposed to have a speaking line.
They told me specifically, don't talk.
But Edward Ramirez comes up to me, you know?
And we had gotten to know each other
he's playing the Bodhi character.
And this is his party scene this over the top,
like crazy yacht.
They had flown in like the most beautiful women
that I've ever seen in my life for some reason, like
from all over the world for this boat scene for this Bodhi.
And so we're just a bunch of bros
like trying to like maintain sanity.
And you're like, there they go,
this is it's incredible.
So we're having a blast.
And finally, we had rehearsed a scene a couple of times
and Edward's like, hey man, you know,
like, you know, get into it.
I was like, okay, but the director was like,
don't worry about that.
(Rich laughs)
Get into it.
You know, that's the type of thing.
Like you got this, I'm like Edward Ramirez, okay, cool.
So he comes up and he's walking through the party
and it's going off and you know, there's women everywhere.
And people jumping skating off the boat.
It's insane, like something
that would never happen in real life.
And he comes up and he shakes my hand and he looks at me,
he's like, hey, my brother and I go, worst party ever.
And we just stop, and then he has his big laugh
and he walks off the rest are like God, God, God,
God damn it, God, God.
And then go back and check the gate and like,
all right that was great we're gonna run that.
(all laughs)
We're gonna run that five times and get coverage on it
and so that's how I got my speaking line.
That's awesome.
In a point or break two.
Get your SAC card from that.
Get your SAC.
Right, nice man.
I wanted to get into, before I let you go
we've got to wind this down a little bit
but I'm super interested in how you have really made fitness
a huge part of your lifestyle
after it kind of got away from you a little bit
and the dedication that you've kind of given
to your wellbeing, not just in the gym
but outside of the gym.
Yeah.
So let's talk about that a little bit.
I mean, I know that you're a huge part
of the deuce CrossFit community
and I've got some friends that work out there.
You share a lot of that on Instagram,
but you go to the Lair workout,
you do the Wim Hof breathing,
you're doing the whole thing.
Yeah.
And you've got a mindfold.
I saw that on your Instagram.
I have a mindfold, I didn't.
I was like, he's on the mindfold.
It's the greatest--
The mindfold is the best.
The greatest $13--
Yeah I know.
That you can spend.
They don't have an IGG.
No, they don't.
Yeah, there's no marketing behind that company?
There's no marketing for the mindfold.
It is the best--
I know that I've sold hundreds of them,
if not thousands just based on responses
and people DM-ing pictures.
(all laughs)
What is that, where do you get that?
From my videos.
It's super cheap,
I bought like four of them.
Yeah, they're 13 bucks.
They're amazing.
I think I ran the New York marathon in 2009
to raise money for my foundation.
I was a foundation that I started called Stoke
to mentoring organization for at risk kids,
exposing them to surfing, skating, snowboarding.
And the principles of it,
the falling down and getting back up,
learning to negotiate a new environment
into building better people.
We've been at it for 15 years and worked with like
over 6,000 kids in New York and L.A and Chicago.
And we were doing this fundraiser where we were
in kind of a lean time in the midst of the recession.
And we needed like, we lost a bunch
of like really big donors.
And I was like, I'll run the marathon, damn, damn idea.
But I, you know, I'm athletic.
In retrospect a good idea.
Yeah, in retrospect, a good idea.
And I ran it.
I only trained for three months.
I lost a bunch of weight while I was training
and thought like, okay, I got this.
And the first for 17 miles, I'm running very, very, very,
very high on adrenaline.
We're looking at like a 415, 420 pace
which is insane for, you know,
a middle-aged guy in his late thirties has never ran before.
But I felt incredible, I was like, this is gonna be--
I already know where this is going.
Awesome.
We actually, sorry we were at a 357 pace.
Sub four, then you hit the Queensborough Bridge.
Dude, how did you know?
Because that's everybody's story
who thinks they're training for a marathon
but actually isn't training the way you're supposed to train
for a marathon mile 18, all falls apart.
The Queensborough Bridge.
(Mabena laughs)
I've never heard anyone else tell it,
but it's the literal moment of truth.
Yeah.
My body said, hi,
I've been enjoying your jubilation,
interaction with the people waving at you
from their windows and the music and all of that
but like--
Puerto Rican's the hustle, all of that, all the colors.
Yeah, and you're just feeling all of that
but shit is not good here.
And now you're going to, it's my turn now.
Time to pay the toll.
Quads, hamstrings, lower back, calves, hip flexors,
all at once gone.
A level of cramping that I didn't even know existed.
And by the time I got to the top of the
also no one tells you the Queensborough Bridge
is a mountain.
Right, yeah.
There's a climb.
It's a climb.
It's an arc.
It's a climb, it's an arc.
You're running on this like weird corrugated
like metally it's just it the arc is real.
And after 17 miles, it's insane.
And I might as well have been climbing Kilimanjaro.
Right (laughs)
And on the back half, I can't even,
the downhill is not relief, it's actually worse.
And now we have six or seven miles to go
where it's a whole new race.
And by mile 21, 22, I'm disintegrated.
My friends who were running with me are like,
come on, you can do it.
I'm crying, I'm waving in and out of consciousness.
Like my body is on fire.
And it was the first time that I actually
like had prayed in a while.
'Cause I literally was like, hey,
if that's you and all that, if you're
this would be a good time to take me.
Noble, raised money I can die rather than finish this.
And the universe all spirits involved were like, nah,
not like this.
And I finally like made to the end.
I think we ended up being like 540 or something.
It was--
That's brutal to go from sub four pace to 540
540 and like broken, like broken.
When my then girlfriend saw me
as I'm coming towards the finish line
where I get that last bit of like reserve adrenaline
where I'm like suddenly my legs are kinda moving,
she saw how destroyed I was.
I saw her eyes and her shock and heart and she's weeping.
And now I'm like the realizing like, oh,
and I'm weeping and I got to the other side and I collapsed.
Couldn't walk for a week.
And I was flying home from New York from there
and I was like, I had to stay
I was working at EOS at the time.
And they, they were like, you're working tomorrow.
I'm head, so I was working out of their offices there.
This is 09?
This is 09.
But on the way home, I was reading an article
and I don't know if it was outside or what
but there was this guy who was talking about
this CrossFit thing and he hated it.
He thought it was the worst thing ever
and it was a crazy fat.
I hadn't heard about it
but he decided to do it for eight weeks.
And at the end of his eight weeks, he was like
everything was better blood, et cetera, et cetera.
It changed his life.
And the way he described it, I was like
I wanna know what this is.
Gymnastics, Olympic lifting.
It's not like going to a gym and using machines.
There's no mirrors.
Yes, I'm curious for what that might be.
Also outside of the Olympics, excuse me,
of the marathon, my surfing and snowboarding
had been steadily in a degrading.
And I was like, but I'm, I know how to do this.
And I'd never really invested time in my body
and going to the gym.
It just felt like a chore.
I had to had gym memberships and trainers
but it just seemed methodical and boring and I like to play.
I like to play basketball, I like to surf and snowboard.
And I came home, I got on YouTube.
I checked out CrossFit and all the videos that came up
were women and these women just like basting,
basting the fitness.
I had no comprehension for what I was seeing,
I was like, yo, if women are,
I could not hang with any of what the tope
taking place here.
I want to do this.
And I called, I literally like Googled whatever
found the closest one, left a message that night,
hey, I want to try your thing,
my name is such and such call me
and then ended up being CrossFit L.A.
And that's how I started.
And that began at a total like weird reset
at 40 into 39 into getting back what you put in
like getting a feedback from fitness,
getting a feedback from what you put in your body.
I realized that as much as I loved playing at the sports,
I literally had no idea how the body works at all.
Like what's happening when you go to lift something
or when you're in a plank or any number of different manners
in which you move the body
and like what you get out of that?
Not to mention food.
Like I just, my mother was, I took my herbs in my shit,
but like, I wasn't, I didn't have a--
But now mom's voice in the back of the head.
I told you I'll waiting for you, literally.
And that began a radical.
I remember the first class I went to.
I didn't know, like any of like
the weird subculture stuff of CrossFit.
I just seemed like cool people.
And it was all my friends at the time
were either artists in Hollywood, surfers or snowboarders.
And so I was like I'm going here to like do this class
and skateboarders now, and then I'm out.
I'm not really here for like--
I'm not gonna join the cult.
Yeah, I'm not here to--
But you also like you like these subcultures.
Didn't realize--
It's community.
And instantly I was like, oh, this is dope.
And these are different types of people from everyday lives.
And we having this commonality
and suddenly I was able to see how it married very nicely
with the other things that I was a part of.
And then I just threw myself like all the way in,
and I've evolved with it, you know,
the work with the body you have today
not the one that you had yesterday, you want tomorrow.
And so I adjusted accordingly as I'm continuing to grow up
but I still am having so much fun.
Like it's given me a new lease on life, you know?
I snowboard better, I surf better than I did 10 years ago.
You know, I can go out and do shit and have fun.
And like, I love playing in the gymnastics of it all.
And then that led to like Lair being like
I see you're taking care of yourself.
One day we were out surfing point doom
he's like, you should come up to my house.
It's like maybe six years ago.
I was like, what?
He's like the golden ticket.
He's like, you got to come up to the house.
Yeah.
And then he like texted me,
like come on, like, come up.
Gates open and then you're just like, whoa.
Now I'm like on some next shit with this with,
you know, wasn't even X.P.T at the time, it was just like
take this dumbbell and jump into the deep end
and walk to the other side.
What, huh?
Yeah, and then we're gonna get in this ice tub
and then we're gonna go sit in this 220 degrees sauna
for 20 minutes.
And then we're going to throw you back in the pool.
And like, you're gonna learn this thing.
And that just opened me up entirely into another world.
Then came the breath working.
I went to a Wim Hof seminar, and I was like, what?
And then the women took an interest in me and like,
I don't know.
Now I'm just like, I'm so wonderfully permanently curious
about what else, like, I know
that I'm never going to learn at all
and anything where you don't get to have mastery over it,
that's what I think I'm built for.
There's always room to grow.
Always room to grow.
And I just enjoy my life so much better with it.
You know, I love how you share it transparently
on Instagram and I think it's inspiring.
And I think it's also interesting how it dovetails
with the evolution of action sports
because when you came up and I know that generation
it's like wasn't cool to like take care of yourself.
You shared the train with a champion mindset
for these things, it's all about talent and swagger, right?
If you won the contest the next day
and you weren't at the bar the night before.
Doesn't count.
It didn't really count.
And people would give you shit like, oh, well,
who do you think you are?
That literally was the mindset.
Yeah, but now it's changed so much
and you know, you see what Kelly's doing,
you see how Lair, you know, leads by example
you look at LeBron and how these guys doubled down
on self care and all the little things that they're doing
and the investments that they're making in themselves
and it's paying off in terms of the longevity
of their career and their ability
to execute at the highest level into, you know,
you know, ages that would have thought
would have been impossible a decade ago.
Absolutely, like I never thought at 49 that I would be,
you know, still riding short boards and like
having the opportunity to push myself
in the back country on a snowboard
so I'm like wouldn't never thought that
that would ever be a thing
or like you know, pause, squatting 275 for fun
and that being lightweight.
And you talked about sharing it on IGG.
You know, the responses that I get
from people from dads,
from people who sort of like let themselves go
or thought they were no longer capable
and them saying like, hey, you, I see you as like me.
And the fact that you're choosing to do this
like has moved me to do this.
Yeah, it was an accessibility to it, it's aspiration.
Yeah, I'm not an elite athlete.
I'm a guy who talks story for a living and loves the thing.
But I've also decided to invest in it as if in myself
as if I was on that level to see where I can take myself.
Yeah, it's cool, man.
It's been fun, you know?
And then that makes you start to get curious
about the mind and, you know, meditation work
and doing some journey with plant medicine
and like really like you start to realize the full
full interconnectedness of all of what this existence is.
Right, but it all comes back
to the spirituality of surfing?
Yes.
And everything can be encapsulated
in that experience of riding the perfect wave, right?
Being completely present,
being completely connected with self being in your bliss,
chasing your passion and being engaged in a community
that supports each other.
Yeah, and I think also being able to have
all of these weird little thin slices
for opportunity at flow state
that can show up in all these different aspects of your life
that like you never thought
you could possibly gain access to.
And then being, like you said,
being able to have community that is supportive
of that in all these spaces.
Yeah, that's me for life now.
You're doing it, man.
You get to live life on your terms,
you get to do the things that you love,
you get to go to cool places.
It's pretty, bad-ass man
It's pretty bad-ass, you know,
and losing the old man a few years ago, you know, really
I think it put it into even sharper perspective, you know?
That yes, I'm doing all of these things
but also none of those things are a guarantee.
Yeah.
So really like be as present as you can
and be okay with the fact that like,
for me like knowing that I'm never going
to have it figured out is the greatest realization
that I've ever been able to come to
'cause then it's just like, we just get to grow
for the rest of the time that we're here, man.
And I'm like, there's gonna be new shit to sort out
but like you're never gonna have it figured out.
So enjoy right now.
I think that's a good place to put a pen in it.
Thanks man.
Thank you, man.
It would appear that everyone that has been working
on behalf of the universe where for us to sit down together,
we're very, very right and I'm really, really humbled
to be able to sit and have this conversation with you.
Right back at you, it's beautiful.
There's so many more, I made all these notes.
There were a thousand things on here
that we didn't even get to.
So to be continued.
We'll do it again.
My friend.
Yeah, thank you, Rich.
Appreciate you, I really admire and respect
the vibration that you carry into the world
I think it's really inspiring
and I think you're an important voice
so the honor is all mine.
Thank you.
We'll do it again.
Right back at you.
So if people wanna connect with you,
what's the best place for them to do that on, on Instagram?
On Instagram, I am @Selema, S-E-L-E-M-A
same it's Selema Masekela on the Twitter.
And then my podcast the What Shapes Us Podcast
and on Instagram it is @whatshapesuspodcast.
And your music's on Spotify.
We din't even get to talk about your bad man.
The music is called Alekesam,
which is simply Masekela backwards.
And yeah, we've got a nice body of work going
and people seem to be enjoying it.
And they find out, I love that people's relationship
with the music is the music first
and then they find out like, oh, it's that guy
I didn't know that.
Didn't put it together, it's better that way.
It's way better that way.
'Cause then you don't have to deal
with all the weird prejudgment stuff.
Which I'd that's a whole another podcast.
(Mabena laughs)
That's a whole another conversation.
But yeah, check out Alekesam anywhere
that you listen to music.
All right, peace brother, thank you.
Thank you, plates.